[musique]
Taniem, bonsoir.
Bonsoir.
Nous vous recevons pour une chaîne
internet qui s'appelle Syerview. On vous
reçoit dans le cadre de votre analyse
sur l'intelligence collaborative,
horizontale, les crapau fou. Qu'est-ce
que vous pouvez nous raconter sur ce
sujet et qui êtes-vous ? Faites-nous une
petite présentation.
comme vous voulez.
Alors bon donc moi j'ai 52 ans, j'ai une
première partie de ma vie qui était très
on va dire classique donc grandes
écoles.
J'ai ensuite travaillé dans le conseil
chez Minen anden Company, c'est une
grosse boîte de conseil. Donc à 30 ans,
j'étais la première femme partenaire en
France et euh voilà une carrière assez
classique qui marchait très bien. Il y a
36 ans, j'en ai eu marre. J'ai eu envie
de faire autre chose que de gagner
beaucoup d'argent. Et donc je suis
partie pour monter une ONG qui
s'appelait Angéus à l'époque et c'était
l'idée de mettre mes compétences au
service d'autres choses qui soient plus
utiles. Et très vite, au début, je
pensais faire, j'ai accompagné pas mal
d'ONG, WWF, le petit panda là, des trucs
comme Nicolaso, les urgentistes et puis
très très vite, je me suis rendu compte
que c'était les mêmes problèmes que dans
l'entreprise, c'est-à-dire la pyramide,
le pouvoir vertical et cetera et ça me
convenait pas. Et donc, je suis tombée
amoureuse à ce moment-là de gens comme
vous, les hackurs. C'est-à-dire, j'ai
rencontré à ce moment-là les gens qui
fabriquaient les ce qui était à l'époque
les débuts des wikis, les CR wiki, tout
ça. Donc, Moose notamment. Et ce garslà,
il eu mon copain vraiment une amitié
assez profonde et très vite les hacurs
sont rentrés dans ma vie. Donc en fait,
on pensait les gens à l'époque pensaient
que tous ces gens-là étaient la silicone
vallée mais en fait une bonne partie
était chez moi en fait chez nous. Et
donc à ce moment-là, on a commencé à
bricoler complètement l'idée de du
durable de toutes ces choses, on va dire
des ONG. On s'est dit est-ce qu'on peut
pas faire autrement ? C'est-à-dire
prendre les principes des hackurs qui
sont finalement assez socratiques, hein,
pour les mettre au service de l'intérêt
général. Et à ce moment-là, on s'est dit
on va tout ouvrir. Donc ce qui était à
l'époque une utopie euh faire une
encyclopédie
partagé par tous, c'était vraiment un
rêve. Et ben 17 ans plus tard, tout le
monde connaît ce truclà. Donc voilà,
c'est depuis 2002, je fais ça. Donc je
m'amuse à bidouiller les trucs. J'avais
36 ans à l'époque et avec Mose, on s'est
dit bah puisque Tan, elle peut aller
chercher des financements, monter des
projets con du sens, lui il m'apportait
la partie hacker et on ouvrait tout ce
qu'on pouvait pour le diffuser. Donc ça
a donné les écoquartiers ouverts. Donc
par exemple à Londres, BZ, il y en avait
à l'époque je crois 250 habitants dans
80 logements. Aujourd'hui, c'est 2
millions dans le monde qui sont inspirés
du premier modèle. Ensuite, il y a eu
les Makers, MIT, tout ça. Après, il y a
eu les Fablab, il y a eu aussi en France
Wisher, Ticket for Chunch, tous ces
jeunes qui se sont dit après tout, une
idée qui a marché pour moi, pourquoi je
la partage pas avec tout le monde ?
C'était ça un peu l'idée que j'ai essayé
de poursuivre depuis donc depuis
maintenant 15 ans. Et puis donc
dernièrement, en 2016, un de mes amis
qui est déjà passé chez vous, Cédric
Villelani, on se connaissait auparavant
en tant que plutôt par les maths et par
les ONG. Et euh voilà, j'ai j'ai eu
cette idée un peu dingue de faire le le
bouquin le manifeste des crapaufous avec
lui et ça je vais en parler un peu plus.
Il y a eu un un choc émotionnel euh
quand vous avez compris ce qui se
passait dans la tête des hackurs. Est-ce
que ça vous c'est est-ce que ça a changé
votre perception du monde ?
Oui. Alors, je pense que c'est je
pourrais le dire comme ça. Je crois que
je me suis pas rendu compte de ce qui se
passait. D'abord, j'étais séduite par la
manière dont fonctionnait notamment
Moose et ses copains. Donc Mose à
l'origine, c'était le leader des
Tikiwiki. Et ce qui m'a intéressé, c'est
la manière dont ces gens fonctionnaient.
Ils me demandaient pas d'argent. Ils
étaient intéressés par le but qu'on
poursuivait. Ils étaient en général très
bons dans ce qui commençait. Ils étaient
complètement bordéliques par ailleurs,
ce qui me convient très bien. Et du
coup, les avoir chez moi, c'était pas
gênant. C'est je pouvais en avoir 10
dans la cuisine qui dormaient par terre
et cetera. Bon, ils faisaient leur vie
mais c'était vraiment pas contraignant
pour moi. Au contraire, j'aime bien
cette façon de faire très très libre.
C'était pas figé, c'était pas formel.
Ensuite, ils avaient des idées qui
étaient assez disruptives. C'est Mos qui
le premier m'a parlé de communauté
apprenante. On était en 2003 2004 et à
l'époque les gens étaient tous dans
l'histoire de collective, les objets qui
font papa, maman, la techno et cetera.
Et en fait, il m'a vraiment mise avec
cette idée que c'est la communauté qui
va créer le savoir et qu'ensuite les
commands, les communs, c'est nous qui
qui les fabriquons. Voilà. Donc, cet
esprit là, je l'ai je l'ai vraiment
étudié avec aussi les exemples de
guilde, de compagnons et cetera. Tout
ça, ça me plaisait vachement. Ensuite à
titre perso, le fait est qu'il est venu
habiter chez moi. Donc on s'est retrouvé
vraiment à partager nos vies quoi avec
sa copine.
Tom amoureuse ?
Non, peut-être intellectuellement mais
physiquement jamais. On est trop dans la
tête pour ce genre de truc hein. Donc
même si on se considère comme frère et
sœur et sa copine par contre était venue
avec lui et moi j'étais avec mon mari de
l'époque et à quatre on a on a vraiment
créé des trucs et le fait de vivre avec
lui au quotidien euh bah j'ai vu ce que
c'est que un mode de vie frugal très
très respectueux de de l'intelligence
collective vu vu au quotidien.
Voilà. Donc ouais, ça m'a ça m'a
vachement ébranlé et ça m'a donné
vraiment envie de me libérer encore
plus. Vraiment, cet esprit que quand on
a un truc, on le partage. Moi, j'avais
la chance d'avoir une maison, d'avoir de
la place, de pouvoir trouver des sous et
lui, il avait vraiment plein d'idées.
Donc, il m'a vraiment aidé à me libérer
et enlever mes mes derniers freins
peut-être à la libération par rapport au
capitalisme et ce genre de choses.
On va parler des crapaufous, mais là, la
dernière phrase m'intéresse beaucoup.
C'est c'est quoi se libérer des freins
du capitalisme, des choses comme ça ? E
bien par exemple euh il y a beaucoup de
gens qui qui vont vous dire euh je peux
pas faire comme toi, sauter dans le
vide, travailler bénévolement et et
mettre toutes mes compétences au service
de l'intérêt général parce que il faut
que je paye mes dettes, parce que euh
j'ai une femme je sais pas quoi, dans un
secondaire, des bagnoles et compagnie.
Du coup, ils partent de l'équation de de
ce qui est contraint et après ils
adaptent l'argent qu'ils vont gagner à
cause de ça. Et moi, je préfère dans
l'autre sens dire qu'est-ce qui me plaît
vraiment ? Je fais d'abord ça et puis
après je me débouille avec l'argent qui
qu'il faut. Je vais voir mes copains, on
se débrouille, on voilà, on fait des
montages, on collabore, on partage des
trucs.
Il se il se focussent uniquement sur le
problème sans se sans sans la solution.
C'est ça.
Voilà. C'est au lieu de chercher voilà,
ils ont toujours des problèmes, ils ont
jamais de solution.
Voilà. Du coup, ils prennent une comme
une contrainte par exemple d'avoir des
temps de trucs à payer. Donc, faut que
je gagne temps pour payer ça. Et du
coup, ben je fais jamais exactement ce
que j'ai envie de faire. Alors que si
vous dites de quoi j'ai vraiment envie,
après vous dites bon ben tant pis, je
sacrifie ceci ou cela, j'allège,
j'abarque et puis du coup je vais
pouvoir d'autant plus me libérer. Par
exemple, je dis souvent à mes étudiants
d'HC et autres que c'est pas forcé
d'être à 100 % d'écart avec ce qu'on
veut faire, mais on peut très bien dire
je gagne mon job, ma vie à 40 % et 60 %
je fais ce qui me plaît. Voilà. Et donc
très
plus grand luxe,
c'est un luxe qu'en fait beaucoup de
gens pourraient s'offrir et c'est ce que
M'a appris. Lui, il avait toujours le
minimum minimum en terme d'argent. il
mettait ses compétences vraiment là où
c'était important. Puis quand c'était
trop galère, il allait gagner un peu
d'argent en faisant quelques tafs par-ci
par là. Puis le reste du temps, sa dette
était vraiment sur les sujets qui
compte. Voilà. C'est pas c'est pas une
dissonance cognitive
d'enseigner à HC et avoir ces valeurs là
qui passe entre vos deux oreilles.
Justement, c'est là qu'on retrouve
c'est un type de hacking.
C'est complètement du hacking. C'est
exactement ça. C'est ça qui me plaît.
D'ailleurs, les étudiants que j'ai pris
HC sont très souvent des hackurs en
réalité, des hackurs de l'économie, des
hackurs de même au sens du code. J'en ai
deux ou trois en tête qui étaient
vraiment câblés comme ça, Pierric et
d'autres. D'ailleurs, le le gars qui a
fait de Kate for Challenge, Mathieu
était un jeune qui venait de d'HC qui
s'est dit après tout si je réussis à
faire une start-up, il faut pas que je
la fasse que pour moi, donc je vais
hacker ce truc et je prends chaque année
50 jeunes que je j'aide à se hacker
aussi. Voilà, donc c'est vraiment une
logique de ce que j'apprends pour moi,
je diffuse aux autres. Donc pour moi,
c'est c'était au contraire. Là, il faut
être exactement dans ce genre de boîte
parce qu'en fait, il y a plein de jeunes
qui qui dépassent du cadre et dire, on
le retrouve chez aussi bien chez Villan
que chez Tadis, c'est des gens qui sont
presque trop intelligents pour ce que le
demande de faire. Donc s'il reste
là-dedans, il meurt. Donc ils sont
obligés de faire des trucs à côté. D'où
l'idée que pour moi un bon hackeur fait
peut-être que 30 ou 40 % d'exercice
imposé, peut-être même plutôt 5 % je
dirais et 95 % de plaisir.
Les crapaux fous, c'est quoi un crapau
fou ? Alors le crapau fou au départ
c'est un truc qui existe réellement,
c'est que dans la nature les crapaux
contrairement à ce qu'on croit ça vit
sur la terre ferme. Et une fois par an
plop plop plop ils vont traverser toutes
les routes pour aller sur la la mar pour
se reproduire. Donc manque de bol pour
eux s'il y a une grosse route au milieu
vu la vitesse à laquelle ils traversent
ils sont tous écrabouillés. Et donc les
écologistes ont demandé à ce que quand
on fabrique une grande route on fasse
des tunnels en dessous pour leur
permettre de traverser. Ça s'appelle des
crapau du voilà comme des viaducces. Et
en fait la réalité c'est que la plupart
se font écrabouiller. Il y a quelques
fous qui trouvent le tunnel en dessous.
Et donc au début avec Cédric Villani, on
s'était dit bah nous on va être les
crapau fous. On on va essayer de trouver
des tunnels qui nous permettront de
sauver l'espèce qui est en danger parce
qu'on voit bien que ça va pas. Donc ça
c'était en 2016. J'étais avec lui en
fait depuis presque un an, je l'aidais
sur une ONG qui s'occupe de handicapé et
de musique, un truc qui s'appelle
Musaïque, il a dû déjà en parler ici. Et
je trouvais ça en fait, c'est une une
ONG qui fait des des instruments de
musique assez extraordinaires et il y a
un peu de techno là-dedans. C'est fait
par un grand artiste qui s'appelle
Patrice Moulet. C'est des espèces de
grands champignons avec des touches.
Vous tapez dessus, ça fait de la
musique. Et en fait, Cédric était
intéressé par le fait que cette machine
qui est assez belle a aussi une vertu
thérapeutique. C'est qu'un jour des
handicapés sont passés à côté. ils ont
commencé à jouer dessus puis ils sont
restés scotchés sur la machine et on
s'est rendu compte que ça les aidait
énormément. Et donc cette ONG fait des
choses vraiment remarquables sur
l'aspect vraiment de empowerment,
c'est-à-dire aider des gens à sortir de
leur niveau peut-être de
d'impossibilité.
Alors du coup, j'étais en train d'aider
Cédric là-dessus. On a fait un débat
public au métalo, maison des métallo en
octobre et puis c'était vraiment
étonnant. On parlait des handicapés avec
Cédric, avec sa la vallère, donc les
grandes idées. Moi, j'apportais tout
cette incubation, tous ces projets de
terrain que j'ai accompagné depuis
maintenant 15 ans. Et à la fin, il y
avait donc la mairie de Paris, il y
avait beaucoup de grands financiers, il
y avait tout le monde était là-dedans.
Et à la fin, donc ils sont venus me voir
en disant "Mais vous êtes un tandem
assez étonnant, le grand esprit avec
l'abeille qui pollinise les idées.
Pourquoi vous vous feriez pas un tandem
? Parce que vous pourriez nous aider à à
voir plus clair sur ce qu'on peut
faire." chiche, on s'est dit bah on va y
aller. Puis Cédric me dit "Attends Tane,
tu es un peu gonflé, tu crois qu'on va
changer le monde comme ça ? Moi j'ai
aucune idée de ce qu'on peut faire. Je
sais mes théores des mathématiques mais
je connais pas le développement durable
et les start-up et tout ça. Je dis bah
chich, on va appeler ça manifeste
puisqu'on ne sait pas. On va dire voilà
le défi qu'on va relever et un peu comme
les indigniés ou les Anonymus, on essaie
de provoquer un changement de de
conscience donc hacker la mentalité des
gens en disant après tout vous écoutez
ce mec avec sa la valière, vous
comprenez qu'il vous dit des trucs vrais
sur les sciences et tout ça et puis il a
accès au plus grand de ce monde. Puis
derrière Tan, elle a fait des trucs qui
vont depuis les les Wikipédia, ce genre
de choses jusqu'à Ticket for Change,
Wish et cetera. Donc peut-être on n pas
la solution mais on y va et on cherche
les tunnels. Donc ça c'était l'équation
au départ du manifeste du crapau fou.
Sauf que quand j'ai commencé au départ
avec Cédric, on se disait bah le le
premier truc qu'on va leur dire c'est
que il y a un tsunami. Il faut le dire
en terme très simple pour monsieur
madame tout le monde. Le tsunami il est
écologique. Donc c'est pas les rapports
du J et de la COP 21. Il faut leur
montrer des choses qui qui peut-être les
touchent plus. Donc on comprend
l'histoire des éléphants, des rondant.
On va leur dire un petit peu quelle est
la réalité mais la simplifier. Sauf
qu'au moment où je démarrais, je me suis
dit le manifeste va commencer par le
tsunami écologique et en fait on est en
octobre. Voilà. Et donc un mois plus
tard et ben on se retrouve avec Trump.
Et là moi j'étais à ce mois-là aux
États-Unis avec mes jeunes entrepreneurs
sociaux. On était une quarantaine et
dans la salle tout le monde était
atterré, c'était les gens pleuraient et
ils disaient "Mais qu'est-ce qui a pu se
passer ?" Donc là, j'ai appelé mes
copains à cœur Mos et compagnie et tous
les gens qui sont euh dire Fleur
Florassur, c'est marrant, je l'ai
rencontré dans dans la foulée. C'est
elle qui a fait le film sur Snowen qui
est passionnant comme
connaissez ses livres ?
Il est passionnant ce enfin
sur sur son documentaire là.
Oui, documentaire passionnant et Snowen
est un personnage absolument euh je
trouve prodigieux ce gars là à 29 ans
qui décide de faire Arakeri pour sauver
la planète quoi.
Vous vous avez lu euh comment j'ai euh
en bande organisée ?
Non, je t'ai pas vu. Non. ou que comment
j'ai liquidé le siècle.
Ah oui oui. Alors j'end ça c'est Flor
Vasseur. Ouais je l'ai pas lu mais j'ai
elle m'a résumé le bouquin. On a fait un
T ensemble juste après Inélix et donc
bref tout ça fait que les hackeurs me
disent ça pue voilà et donc à l'époque
il commence à me parler de Cambridge
Analytica et tout ça. Voilà et c'est
comme ça d'ailleurs que j'ai rencontré
Fabrice et Pelboin dont tu parlais tout
à l'heure qui est aussi un cœur assez
courageux qui a qui a vraiment essayé de
secouer le cocotier. Et donc deuxième
tsunami, je me rends compte que la
démocratie a été complètement malmenée
par le big data et par la manière dont
les données ont été manipulé pour faire
basculer les gens qui hésitaient entre
Trump et Clinton.
Je te coupe.
Ouais.
Euh tu parles d'Astring là ?
Euh tu parles de tsunami écologique.
Tu essayes de trouver des des points
d'adhérence avec la plebe, si je peux me
permettre de dire la plebe,
des cérébrés de temps en temps, non ?
Est-ce que tu penses pas qu'il y a
une incapacité cognitive ? Est-ce qu'on
a pas passé une un point de non retour
auprès de notre pleb ? parce qu'ils sont
pas trop intoxiqués par des phénomènes
de
neuromarketing,
de communication façon Chopenhaer, de
communiquants qui travestissent la
langue française, qui tordent la
rhthorique pour s'approprier
la, on va dire qui tordent la
dialectique pour s'approprier le contenu
de des choses. Est-ce que tu penses pas
que tu te tu te bats un peu contre des
moulins ? Et qu'est-ce qui t'anime en
fait ?
Alors, il y a beaucoup de choses à dire
pour te répondre. La première chose
temps, ça tombe bien.
La première chose, c'est que en fait, il
y a ensuite un troisème tsunami qui est
encore peut-être plus important que les
deux premiers. Si on dit qu'il y a
l'écologie, ensuite la la pollution
mentale que qu'un bridge et a pu faire
en manipulant les données, donc
l'information, le discernement. La
troisième, c'est tous ces objets qu'on a
dans nos poches, des smartphones, toutes
ces machines, ces espions en fait hein.
Donc ça va aller depuis votre montre,
jusqu'à ton téléphone, ton ordinateur et
cetera, jusqu'à ton frigidaire, demain
ta bagnole. Tous ces machins sont des
objets qui nous englobent effectivement
comme tu dis qui font que la plebe pour
prendre ton expression est de plus en
plus devenu l'esclave de ces machine qui
pense à notre place. Donc le troisème
problème étant différent du deuxème le
deuxème c'est vraiment la manipulation
des esprits et le trème c'est toutes ces
machines qui nous remplacent. Mais alors
par rapport à ta question de la plebe,
j'ai observé il y a 15 ans quand j'ai
commencé en 2000 avec l'écologie à
l'époque un phénomène que j'appelais le
TLM. Le TLM, c'est un mot québécois qui
veut dire toujours les mêmes.
L'idée, c'est que quand tu vas dans une
réunion à l'époque pour l'écologie,
c'était les TLM qui venait toujours
gueuler pour les colibries, pour le
nucléaire, pour je sais pas tout quoi.
Donc c'est toujours les mêmes qu'on va
retrouver dans les réunions de quartier,
dans les réunions d'écol. Donc ces
gens-là ont un truc très ciblé. Puis
après quand tu vas prendre un problème
aujourd'fugié, tu vas avoir des TLM mais
ça sera d'autres TLM. Et après quand tu
vas avoir un truc, voilà. Donc l'idée
c'est que chacun a son problème, son
allergie polaire, on va dire. Donc qui
fait qu'il réagit sur le truc qu'il voit
ici. Et donc en fait si on prend la
somme des gens et qu'on trouve le truc
qui les fait réagir, on a peut-être une
chance que ce soit pas des des gens qui
vont se laisser bouffer la plebe, la
structurfing où on se laisse
complètement embarquer par le discours
dominant. Mais le problème c'est que
chacun a son point, tu vois. Et nous
l'hypothèse des crapau, c'est justement
qu'en faisant un truc
transdisciplinaire,
transversal, transgénérationnel, trans
tout ce que tu veux, on va faire
beaucoup plus effet pour commencer à
bousculer le système dominant. Sachant
que si tu ramènes les problématiques à
trois gros enjeux, tu vois que là tu
touches déjà beaucoup plus de gens
simultanément. Quand tu leur parles des
machines aujourd'hui, en plus avec un
dédicace, c'est plus facile. Quand tu
leur parles des gars femmes et de ce
qu'on fait avec un smartphone et les
parents sont inquiets de voir leur gamin
scotcher sur la machine pendant 4
heures, tu vois. Donc il se passe
qu'aujourd'hui quand je vais dans une
réunion et je fais mes conférences de
crapau, à la fin j'ai 10 fois plus de
gens qui viennent me parler en ligne.
10 fois plus de gens sur combien ? pas
beaucoup effectivement, mais si tu veux
sur les écologistes, on était peut-être
1 à 2 % de gens qui s'inquiétaient du
bio à l'époque et qui s'inquiétaient des
des pesticides. Aujourd'hui, quand tu
parles des problèmes des écrans, tu vas
avoir facilement allez 30 30 % des
parents qui sont inquiets pour leurs
gamins, qui sont décérébrés avec bah
justement l'invasion des machines. Et
quand tu commences à parler de la
démocratie, de ce qui s'est passé avec
Trump, du fake news et tout ça, je pense
que là aussi tu as bien deux personnes
sur 10 au moins qui disent qu'ils ont
plus confiance dans ce qu'on leur dit.
Donc je pense quand même qu'on a on a
aujourd'hui atteint un seuil de bascule
parce qu'il y a beaucoup de choses qui
sont dans dans le quotidien partout et
que les gens commencent à en avoir
conscience. Je pense qu'il y a une
convergence aujourd'hui.
Tu penses ou c'est simplement une vue de
l'esprit ? Attends 2 secondes. Non,
c'est pas moi les gars. Euh, est-ce que
tu penses Est-ce que tu penses que c'est
on va avoir une une masse inertielle
suffisamment importante pour
contrecarrer le on va dire les pubs, les
séries télé, les télééalités,
des choses comme ça ?
Alors, je ne peux pas faire de de boules
de cristal. Ce que je sais en tout cas,
c'est pas tu es pas prospectiviste.
Non non, par contre, je ne suis pas non
plus utopiste. Je pense que je suis
combative. Par contre, je vois des
signaux faibles pour paraphraser mon ami
Mathieu Baudin qui font que ces femmes
signaux faibles commencent à faire un
peu effet de masse. Et c'est vrai que
dans le bouquin du crapau fou, je
postule que la somme des trois peut
faire un changement de phase. Donc les
trois tsunamis écologique, machine et
puis fake news. C'estàdire que c'est
comme quand l'eau devient vapeur, tu
vois. Donc moi, je pense qu'on n'est pas
loin de ce moment et je te donnerai
quelques exemples dans ce sens-là. Donc
déjà les corpores, les gens avec
lesquels on bosse, il y a quand même pas
mal de grosses boîtes. On peut dire
c'est pas des gentils tout ça tout ça
mais je vois des grandes entreprises qui
commencent vraiment à donc par exemple
NG avec Isabelle Cocher qui fait quand
même des choses assez étonnante en
matière d'engagement sur la transition
écologique et quand tu vois ces équipes
ce qu'ils font il y a vraiment des
équipes avec eux on fait des choses
assez assonnantes avec les crapau fous
mais les milliers donc on aime on aime
pas c'est Decathlon Laur Merlin Auchamp
et Mchamp ils ont également écrit des
choses dans le bouquin et [grognement]
je trouve qu'ils font un travail assez
intéressant d'ouverture justement par
rapport à donner accès aux gens à
certain niveaux niveau de d'être acteur.
C'est un petit peu ce qu'on fait avec le
roi Merlin et un peu avec des catlons.
Bon, on peut le discuter ou pas, mais je
trouve qu' il y a quand même quelque
chose qui est en train de se passer. Et
là, je je commence à travailler avec un
gars qui est assez remarquable s'appelle
David Lee qui est en Shenzen. C'est lui
qui est en train de complètement de
révolutionner à l'internet des objets.
Ouais. Ouais.
Il y a beaucoup de choses qui sonnent
chez vous.
Ouais. Ouais. Non mais il y a beaucoup
de choses. Ouais, c'est moi. Je suis
désolé. Je te relance je te relance sur
les crapaufous.
Euh je vais juste couper le portable.
Éteindendre. Autant pour moi qui ne veut
pas se couper, c'est pour ça qu'il
ressonne depuis trois fois. Et euh
est-ce que tu peux expliquer l'astro
turfing ?
Oui.
Alors l'astrurfing c'est euh au départ
c'est un truc qui a été inventé par
Monsanto. Ils avaient un produit pour
faire pousser je sais plus quelle plante
qui s'appelait l'astro. Et le turfing,
c'est une allion au grassroot parce
qu'en anglais les grassroots, c'est les
classes moyennes. Et en fait l'idée
c'est que quand tu tu mets ce ce produit
dessus, c'était l'idée de transformer
les donc les petites pousses en gazon.
Et en en anglais, le gazon, c'est le le
turf. Donc c'est comment tu transformes
les grass roots en turf grâce à ce
produit d'astro. Donc c'est un peu
l'idée que en inondant les
grasserousses, donc les les des gens
moyens avec ces produits censé être
magnifiques, bah les gens allaient
devenir une pelouse. Donc c'est pour ça
qu'on appelait ça astrotorfing mais en
fait c'est de la toxe. Donc par exemple
ce qu'il faisait avec l'astrotorfing
c'est qu'il prenait des gens pour faire
des photos de trucs qui étaient faux qui
donnai l'impression que 1000 personnes
s'étaient réunies pour dire vive l'astr
l'astro le produit. Et on sait que les
Chinois ont fait la même chose à une
époque, ils avaient je crois des je
crois que c'est des centaines de
milliers de gens qui cliquaient sur des
trucs pour donner l'impression que des
foules étaient pour telle ou telle
chose. Donc tout ça c'est la
manipulation en trompant les les masses
populaires avec des images qu'on a rendu
viral mais qu'ils sont pas.
Ça a eu des conséquences ? Est-ce que tu
sais si ça a déjà eu des conséquences en
dehors de l'élection américaine ? Ben,
je crois bien qu'il y a eu une histoire
de Samsung ou une je crois que c'est
Samsung, j'espère que je me trompe pas,
où ils ont comme ça lancé un produit
avec de l'astroturfing en prétexant que
le machin avait vachement marché alors
que c'était faux. Il y a eu au moins cet
exemple là. Il y a aussi l'exemple de
l'astro donc de de Monsanto et puis bien
sûr les exemples de Trump. Il y a aussi
je crois le Brexit. Il me semble qu'il y
a eu aussi un truc du même genre. Euh
j'ai pas vérifié cette source là mais il
me semble qu'on a on a cin ou six cas de
cette nature là.
Donc la structure fing, les fake news,
comment on fait pour endurcir l'esprit
critique de la masse, de la plebe ?
Comment on fait ?
Alors la le fake news déjà c'est on
pourrait dire c'est un phénomène assez
ancien puisque l'atox a toujours existé
hein déjà les années 2000 lax pour les
produits laitiers et tout ça et cetera
bon on connaît mais la différence
aujourd'hui c'est qu'avec les fake c'est
conçu d'une telle manière que c'est
vraiment formaté pour vraiment rentrer
dans les réseaux sociaux c'est-à-dire
qu'on sait quelles sont les nouvelles
qui marchent bien elles sont des
caractéristiques virales souvent il y a
des images un peu choc il faut des
messages très simples et cetera donc
c'est c'est très souvent des trucs
idiots qui qui sort de l'ordinaire et on
sait que les fake marchent mieux quand
c'est négatif que quand c'est positif.
Tu vas pas faire un fake avec les
cérisiers sont en fleur, ça marche au
Japon mais pas trop ici. Donc l'autre
chose également c'est que deuxième chose
c'est que tu prends des espèces de
cheval de trois. C'est que tu prends des
gens qu'on va appeler des useful idiots
ou ça qu'on les appelle des des idiots
utiles. On leur fait croire que on on
arrange l'information de telle manière
que la personne peut la croire et de
manière qu'à ce que si elle le like,
tous ses copains sont affectés. Donc
après, il suffit de truquer la source
Times magazine, tu enlèves le s des
choses comme ça et tu fais une une de
journal qui a l'air d'être vrai mais en
fait c'est pas le vrai magazine au
départ. Tout ça fait que des gens un peu
crédules vont plus facilement répercuter
l'info et une fois que c'est rentré par
eux, ça rentre partout. Crédule ou
crétin ?
Euh bah crétin c'est un peu méchant
ou réaliste,
je sais pas. Tu sais euh
chrétinisme c'est pas une insulte, c'est
une pathologie.
Ouais. Alors je sais pas au départ
c'était quoi le chrétinisme ?
Pathologie. Non
je suis pas sûr. Euh parce que par
exemple l'idiot l'idiot tel que le
définit Dostoevski, c'est pas quelqu'un
de d'inutile en fait. L'idiot c'est
quelqu'un qui pose des questions, qui
dit "Mais par rapport au reste du
groupe, je vois pas les choses de la
même façon. Est-ce que c'est c'est moi
14 ou Donc dans l'idiosie, il y a
parfois quelque chose de de salvateur.
Euh et alors pour moi du coup dans le
mot ple je sais pas si c'est connoté
négativement à l'origine chez les Grecs.
J'en suis pas sûr d'ailleurs, parce que
tu vois dans le le modèle grec de la
gora, c'était la plebe qui qui devait
poser les questions. Ensuite, on devait
instruire les sujets. Il y avait un
débat qui était vraiment instruit par
les gens. Et c'est seulement à la fin
qu'on demandait à un expert de dire oui
ou non par rapport à ce qui a été
rapporté. En creusant, on peut dire que
un tel ou pas a raison. Mais il fallait
au départ que les gens posent des
questions benoîtement pour qu'on puisse
vraiment aller voir tout et qu'on ait
pas une seule voix euh sur les
problèmes. Les crapau fous fous c'est
conoté négatif non ? Alors pour moi non
les fous justement s'il y avait pas de
laisse passer la lumière c'est ça
voilà exactement parce qu'il est fêé il
laisse heureux et le crapau fou parce
que fé il laisse passer la lumière moi
je pense que dans un monde qui est fou
celui qui est fou c'est le seul qui peut
sauver le système
vas-y continue.
Bah le fou c'est celui qui reste dedans.
Qui sait que le machin va dans le mur et
qui reste dedans. Pour moi, c'est c'est
démand de rester à bord. Donc
heureusement c'est comme tu sais en
mathématiqu moins moins égale plus. Donc
euh voilà, s'ils sont tous fous, au
mieux de fous que rester aussi fous
queeux.
Et être adapté dans une société folle,
c'est c'est fou ou pas ?
Moi, j'aime bien l'histoire du merginal
séquant. Je sais pas si tu connais
celle-là. C'est l'idée que le le
changement innovation vient toujours par
quelqu'un qui a une patte dans le
système et une patte de l'autre côté. Il
est séquent parce que du coup, il est
capable de sortir du système mais de de
rerentrer dedans. C'est exactement
l'image de Matrix. Quand Néo prend le
téléphone, il rentre dans la matrice
mais il sait en sortir. Son problème à
lui, c'est de faire assez de dégâts
quand il rentre dans la matrice mais pas
rester bloqué dedans. Donc le problème
pour moi, le crapau, c'est exactement la
même chose. C'est quels sont les tunnels
ou les coups de téléphone pour sortir de
ce truc où il rentrai pour pouvoir
bouger les choses à l'intérieur et
ensuite vite sortir des gens de la
matrice, le méroving et cetera. Tu vois,
c'est ce genre de personnalité. J'adore
les les images qu'il y a là-dedans, mais
je pense que c'est un peu la même
histoire avec Luke Skywalker qui au
départ est un pékin moyen. Un jour, il
tombe sur la tête parce que sa mère a
été assassinée ou je sais plus quoi et
il décide de devenir un Jedi alors qu'au
début, il veut pas. Et je crois que tout
le monde c'est la même chose, c'est
qu'au départ le monde dans lequel on vit
est pas parfait et les gens l'acceptent
plus ou moins. Donc on est toujours dans
cette histoire. C'est les TLM qui vont
s'occuper du problème mais moi je suis
pas touché. Puis le jour où tu prends un
coup dans la gueule là, tu dis "Ben non,
je je proteste, je veux aussi faire
partie de la solution." Et nous le
crapaufou c'est de dire vous avez tous
un truc sur lequel vous pouvez apporter
quelque chose. Donc dans les crapaux on
encourage la diversité. Par exemple dans
le bouquin, il y a pas mal de gens qu'on
appu casque dans dans les crapaux qui
eux-mêmes disent voilà on est pour la
reconnaissance de nos différences. Donc
les fameux troubles du spectre
autistique. Donc ça donne des aspergeurs
ou des autistes. Donc des gens sont très
intelligents ou très débiles entre
guillemets v par les autres mais
simplement ils sont différents. Donc
nous on dit avec votre différence vous
pouvez vous pouvez créer de la valeur.
Sauf que moi j'ai écrit ça il y a un an.
Aujourd'hui tout le monde se jette sur
les autistes et les aspergers pour les
mettre dans les start-ups. Bah voilà on
était encore en avance sur le temps. La
même manière où on s'intéresse beaucoup
aux gens qui sont borderline moi je
connais bien, j'ai un petit peu ce
syndrome là aussi. Donc quand tu es
borderline, tu vois tout super en
positif ou super en négatif et donc du
coup tu es obligé de courir toujours
plus vite pour aller du côté positif.
Bon bah ces gens-là sont des grands
créateurs. Bon je peux donner Lady Die
ou Marline Monro. Bon créatif à leur
manière mais c'est tous des gens qui
avaient une souffrance en eux qui les
obligent à avancer. Et comme on en
discute souvent chez les crapoufous, il
y a une certaine souffrance là-dedans
parce que c'est un package. Tu choisis
pas d'avoir ça, ce pète au casque qui
t'oblige à avancer mais parce que tu as
cette différence, bah quand tu trouves
d'autres qui comme toi ont cette
différence, c'est très motivant pour
faire court, se mettre ensemble et
commencer à trouver des solutions et les
partager. Donc
nous, on appelle ça une malédiction.
Bah malédiction jusqu'à ce que tu la
retournes, ça peut être aussi un sort,
tu sais. Le charme. Le charme c'est
intéressant comme mot d'un point de vue
analytique parce que quand tu as un
charme qui est jeté à quelqu'un, la
personne est comme ça, elle peut plus
bouger et quand tu rendons le charme, tu
peux devenir autre chose. Dans le cir
des anneaux, on voit le le vieux roi là
qui est complètement comme ça là. Puis
au moment où le le charme du vieux
serpent est enlevé, le mec il renaît, il
redevient l'homme qu'il était avant. Et
c'est un peu cette image aussi que je
crois qu'on a tous. On a peut-être un
peu cet aveuglement par tous les
systèmes qu'on nous envoie, tout ce que
tu disais, le marketing, toutes ces
images, tous les trucs d'Instagram, les
trucs et les machins et qu'en fait c'est
simplement au contact de soi-même qu'on
qu'on peut renaître et devenir vraiment
acteur de sa vie. Donc le vrai message
du crapafou, il est là. Et les 34 qui
m'ont aidé à écrire ce bouquin au-delà
de Cédric Villanis au départ et
l'éditeur sont tous des gens qui ont
déjà expérimenté cette différence et qui
l'ont valoriser qui ont travaillé sur
leur faille et sur leur faiblesse pour
en faire une force et ensuite du coup
avoir envie de la partager avec les
autres.
Ça ça crée pas de la jalousie ?
Ben
la défiance du système établi.
Alors curieusement, tu vois, c'est je
fais une analogie qui qui est vraiment
celle que je vis moi euh avec un une
entrée particulière par le prisme des
gens qui sont holiques, donc workolque.
À l'époque chez Mckins j'étais
workolque, je bossais comme une tarée,
beaucoup trop.
Tu avais une Porsche ?
J'avais une Porsche, j'avais je
m'habillais en Arménie comme je raconte
bien allé. Euh ouais, c'était un un
style de vie ce qui était qui était
aussi accompagné par du sport de compète
et le soir j'intéressais au Queen face
de de Mckin pour aller danser avec les
gens de la nuit jusqu'à Pasur, les
muglerurs et cetera. Donc j'ai connu
aussi le côté mannequin. J'ai même une
époque fait des photos et donc tout ça
c'était complètement du du boul ta vie
par les 10 bouts. Donc ça c'est ce que
je faisais à l'époque. Donc j'avais un
côté holque. Après le work c'est traduit
par du sportic. le sport, si c'était pas
ça, c'était alcoolique donc je buvais
beaucoup et et aussi boulimique, donc je
capable de manger beaucoup. Enfin, tout
ça, c'est je voulais ma vie par tous les
côtés. Et donc ça c'est une malédiction.
Au départ, je l'ai vécu comme telle.
C'est ce qui explique j'en sois là
aujourd'hui parce que j'ai j'ai été très
tellement vite dans ma vie d'avant mais
c'était pas une vie agréable du tout. Tu
peux imaginer comme tu te brûles avec ce
genre de truc. Mais donc pour le coup,
je pense que personne m'envrait de dire
j'ai je suis passé par ces cases,
boulimie, alcoolisme, tous ces trucs-là,
c'est pas très agréable. Mais c'est ce
qui explique peut-être que j'en suis là
aujourd'hui. Du coup, j'ai pas de
jalousie sur ce que j'ai été. Et
aujourd'hui, quand j'en parle, les gens
m'en veulent pas. Ils se disent "Bah,
elle a guéri d'un truc, ça lui a fait du
bien. Elle le partage avec d'autres qui
du coup sont contents de savoir que j'ai
fait ce chemin-là et j'ai envie de le
partager avec ces gens-là en
particulier."
Donc c'est comme si on était une coorte
de gens qui ont vécu une certaine
difficulté dans leur vie et on la
partage. C'est comme les groupes pour le
cancer, les groupes pour l'alcool, pour
les narcotiques. Tous ces groupes de
narcotiques anonymes, tu sais les
groupes anonymes marchent très bien.
Pourquoi ? Parce que c'est des pères.
C'est des gens qui ont vécu quelque
chose de dur qui l'ont partagé. Et c'est
pour moi le la racine même du hackur,
c'est parce que tu partages quelque
chose qui qui compte pour toi avec des
gens qui font le même chemin de décoder
le truc que tu vas entretenir ce ce bien
commun. Donc du coup, moi je déteste les
consultants qui viennent te dire pour un
boulimique faut faire ça, ça marche pas.
Ils savent pas ce que c'est que d'être
boulimique. Et de la même manière quand
tu es à cœur que tu as mis les mains
dans le code, tu sais comment ça marche.
Donc tu as tous les gens qui vont faire
semblant, qui vont habiller le truc, ils
vont essayer de te le piquer. Ces
gens-là, c'est ceux justement je balay
en verre de la main. Donc j'ai jamais
fait de conseil moi en fait depuis que
depuis 15 ans que je fais ça. Je fais
que de bosser avec des gens qui sont
vraiment les mains dans le cambouille,
qui résolvent un problème et qui veulent
le partager. Tadis, c'est comme ça.
Vilan aussi. Bon, mais j'en j'en ai des
exemples plein plein plein de de ces
jeunes qui avaient envie de de résoudre
un problème qui leur parlait et qui du
coup onune envie, c'est de partager ce
bien. Et je dis souvent l'économie du
don, c'est ça parce que tu as trouvé
quelque chose, tu l'as de quantité
infinie. Si tu es bon en pa tu as envie
de le partager, tu es bon en côte, tu as
envie de le partager.
Je politique
euh Ouais, éventuellement, ça dépend
pour quoi faire effectivement. Mais mon
idée c'est que plus tu as de de talent
que tu as trouvé, que tu as cultivé,
plus tu as envie de le donner et du coup
plus tout le monde va s'élever. Voilà.
Une question très intéressante
d'Internet. D'ailleurs, on remercie pour
cette question. Comment guérir ceux qui
nous gouvernent ? [grognement]
ça
déjà peut-être qu'il faudrait que ceux
qui nous gouvernent ne soient pas
je dirais
omnipotent mais que nous-même on puisse
nous gouverner nous-même. C'est-à-dire
dans des mouvements comme les barbares
et tu vois dans Antoine Brachet ces gens
qui ont commencé avec euh challenge.org
t tous les trucs qui qui sont présentés
aux élections la dernière fois là avec
Charles de marchandise et tout ça, on
voit qu'il commence à émerger des choses
de la société civile qui dit "Nous
aussi, on peut peser sur le système
électoral." Donc je pense qu'il y aura
un mouvement bottom up qui peut déjà
j'espère en tout cas
de base en haut
de Ouais. du bas vers le haut qui pourra
se faire entendre un petit peu plus.
Donc déjà de
c'est pas utopique ça. Est-ce que ça
sert pas en fin de compte ceux qui nous
gouvernent ? parce que on va dire c'est
c'est un peu comme François Ruffin ou
[grognement] un peu d'ailleurs, on lui
passe le bonjour.
C'est pas une une petite caution genre
vous pouvez encore vous trémousser, être
un peu turbulent mais en fin de compte
on est toujours aux manettes et que les
mégalot qui nous gouvernent vont pas
bouger. Est-ce que c'est pas plus
contre-productif
de laisser un espoir
que d'y aller franchement ?
J'avoue que j'ai j'ai souvent ce doute,
hein. C'est pour ça que pour ma part,
j'ai jamais fait de politique et je
crois que j'en ferai jamais. Même quand
Cédric a décidé de partir en politique,
quand on a découvert le coup de
Cambridge et qui se dit "Beye bye les
gars, continuez votre chemin." C'était
clair, la copie était claire. Lui, il
montait dans dans l'arène avec Macron et
tout ça. C'est son choix. Moi, j'ai pas
d'avis à porter là-dessus. Mais nous,
les 34 qui sommes totalement apolitiques
dans le crapau fou, on s'est dit, on
continue notre chemin à faire les
tunnels et notre but, c'est de faire
plein de tunnels, plein de tunnels sous
le mammouth pour qu'un jour le mammouth,
poum il tombe par terre. Tu vois ? Donc
moi, je continue à faire mes tunnels, ce
qui fait que du coup sur la question
politique, je suis presque totalement
irrelevante. J'ai pas tellement d'avis.
Ce que je regarde plutôt, c'est comment
euh déformer déformater la personne qui
a le pouvoir en tant que personne. Et
là, je dois dire, j'ai remarqué un truc
très intéressant. Depuis que je fais le
crapau, depuis maintenant près de 6
mois, j'ai pas mal de grands décideurs,
je vais pas donner leur nom, mais dans
les grands corporettes, au niveau aussi
parfois des grandes institutions qui
viennent me voir en disant "Ah bah
tiens, j'ai un enfant qui est autiste,
ton discours m'intéresse, est-ce que tu
peux m'aider à titre personnel ?" Et là,
du coup, il se passe quelque chose
d'autre. Je l'emmène dans mon petit
tunnel à moi et là du coup bah on
discute et c'est pas une négociation, je
te donne ça, tu me donnes ça, c'est de
comprendre sa propre souffrance puis de
l'emmener à regarder les choses
différemment. Et du coup, si tu peux
l'aider à réfléchir différemment, à
certain moment il peut t'aider à faire
des choses. Je donnerai pas son nom,
mais il y a un gars comme ça qui est qui
est assez puissant, qui a pas mal aidé
des écoles alternatives
à Paris et qui du coup a un cas de
figure de cette nature là qui du coup
envie de m'aider. J'ai pas mal de grands
sponsors aussi qui ont des fondations
qui ont tous un gamin qui est différent.
Donc très souvent l'entrée par le gamin
qui est maltraité à l'école qu'il soit
TDAH ou éventuellement autiste ou
simplement 10 quelque chose.
TDAH il faut expliquer hein.
Alors TDH c'est troupe déficit de
l'attention et hypersensible. Donc c'est
des gamins hyperactifs. Donc quand c'est
juste comportemental on va dire c'est
bon le former l'éduquer un petit peu.
Mais dans pas mal de cas ça se traduit
par des médicaments comme la réthaline
qu'il faut leur prendre sans quoi
neuronalement ça fonctionne pas. Ils
sont ils arrivent pas à connecter les
trucs donc ils sont toujours comme ça et
donc c'est une vraie souffrance pour eux
et pour leurs parents.
L'aritaline c'est pas un peu la molécule
de l'obéissance ?
Ça je sais pas. Je connais des gens qui
ont réussi à s'en passer alors qu'ils
avaient le trouble TDH. Et je connais
aussi des gens qui n'arrivent pas à s'en
passer donc je sais pas où mettre la
barre. Je connais aussi quelqu'un dans
le bouquin d'ailleurs Fabien Caselis qui
a écrit sur les les autistes Asperger
qui est chercheuse au CNRS qui a réussi
à vraiment sortir ses gamins de
l'autisme et de l'asperger sans leur
faire prendre de médoc. Donc ça veut
dire qu'on peut y arriver mais il faut
le prendre très tôt. D'où l'importance
de du diagnostic avancé et surtout
d'apprendre aux gens à s'autoréguler.
C'est vraiment cette logique de pas
mettre les gens dans une case et là
médicaments et cetera, c'est en amont
faire le maximum pour que les parents et
les enfants puissent travailler sur
eux-mêmes, les mettre en confiance
aussi, les mettre dans un environnement
adapté et cetera et cetera. Donc j'ai
pas tout à fait la bonne la ganja. Non
pardon.
Ou fumer de la ganja.
C'est quoi ça ?
Du cannabis.
Ah non non. J'ai jamais pris de Tu as
jamais pris de cannabis ?
Non, moi seul vis, moi j'ai dû esser
mais ça m'a strictement rien fait.
J'étais de façon tellement allumée déjà
que je pas besoin de ça. Mon seul v je
te dis c'est plutôt j'aime bien boire,
j'aime bien, j'adore les les bulles, le
champagne, le cré j'aime bien boire un
bon coup, j'aime bien manger. Voilà. Et
puis à certain moment, je m'étais
accommodé de ça avec ces ces ces
systèmes, tu vois, pour pas grossir.
Voilà.
Attends de voir ce qui va après
l'interview. On va t'inviter au resto.
Le green washing, bon ou mauvais signe ?
Question d'internet. le green washing à
l'époque des écolos.
Ouais, c'estàd le le le le les éoliennes
vont nous sauver, tout va bien. Aller,
la science et la technologie vont nous
sauver.
Ah oui, non. Alors ça, moi je pense que
le green washing ça porte bien son nom.
J'ai jamais pensé que c'était une bonne
solution. C'est très souvent le le le
truc qui cache
comment dire, c'est la cô une jambe de
bois pour moi très souvent. D'ailleurs,
le mot lui-même veut dire je nettoie
tout en mettant du green dessus. Donc à
l'époque des 2000 cette époque-là
c'était on s'achète une bonne conscience
en se mettant une estampie du d'une on
verte quelle qu'elle soit. Dans d'autres
cas, on faisait un peu des RSE, tu vois.
Moi, je trouve ça pas très sérieux.
C'est faire moins mal la même chose.
Mais bon, c'est toujours un début de
quelque chose. Ça a permis de grapiller
un peu de budget pour faire avancer des
projets pilotes. Mais comme je dis
souvent aussi bien que tous les projets
que j'ai conduit, pour moi, il s'agit
pas de faire moins mal la même chose, il
s'agit de faire quelque chose qui a du
sens. Donc d'emblé, je pense que le truc
est pas bon. C'est pas comme ça qu'on y
va. Donc pour moi, j'ai jamais voulu
faire ni RS ni ces choses-là. J'ai
toujours cherché aussi bien à chausser
qu'ailleurs, à trouver le zèbre, le
crapau et l'aider à réussir à faire
autre chose dans le système. Donc c'est
ça qui qui a conduit à des tickets for
challenge et des choses comme ça.
Je vais inclure le facteur temps dans
ton prisme de lecture et dans ton
action. C'est pas trop tard de de
propager ces idées dans la population.
Est-ce que ce tsunami qui nous attend
euh multiple est pas trop important ?
Est-ce que c'est pas le
son du violon sur le pont du Titanic ?
Alors justement, je crois que c'est le
moment génial où il y a des
convergences. D'ailleurs, je suis avec
le Dil Lama sur un projet global euh qui
inclut d'ailleurs aussi les Chinois qui
est un projet de réveil des conscience
parce que quand on a sorti notre bouquin
en même temps, il y avait le le livre
qui sortait du Dalil Lama qui s'appelait
le réveil des consciences appel à la
jeunesse notamment la jeunesse
française. Et dans ce bouquin, il dit
Lama dit quand il y a eu le Bataclan,
j'ai arrêté de croire en religion.
Ah bah il était temps.
Mais vous imaginez un chef OG qui dit ça
et donc il est parti tu as un ami
imaginaire. Tu crois en Dieu ?
Non, pas du tout.
B continue sur le Ilama.
Et donc il a il a fait ce bouquin en
disant je ne crois qu'en une chose à la
jeunesse. Il faut absolument monter tout
le monde à bord et le bouquin au même
moment. Le nôtre sans que j'ai vu lui le
daama, j'avais cris la même chose.
J'avais mis la génération 2030 ces gens
enfin 2050 ceux qui seront aux manettes.
Donc c'est les 18 35 ans de maintenant.
Et j'avais dit il faut absolument leur
donner les manettes tout de suite mais
pas leur dire dessinez-moi la planète tu
es bien gentil mais leur dire vous allez
être en aux commande maintenant. Donc
vous formez l'économie, tout ça en
accéléré. Et donc moi je crois que tout
l'enjeu c'est eux, c'est même en fait
les 14 35 ans. Donc toi tu fais partie
d'eux je pense. Et et pour moi l'enjeu
c'est de leur donner tout de suite non
seulement les manettes économiques mais
également politiques et cetera. Donc
tout ça c'est bien écrit dans le
manifeste et moi je mets l'accent
vraiment à aller chercher ces gens-là.
Et donc le chinois dont je te parlais
tout à l'heure qui est Shenzen, il fait
un programme accéléré avec des trucs
incroyables. Des gamins de 14 ans qui te
font un smartphone en quelques heures
qui vaut 50 € et qui marche très bien,
qui te fait un drone en quelques heures
pareil, un rover tout en do yourself
self open source. C'est David Lee à
Shenzen. Ce type est absolument génial.
Il est en train de donner le pouvoir aux
jeunes. Donc dans les banlieux, dans
dans les campagnes, il est en train de
casser le modèle de la Silicon Vallé. Là
où les gens dans les modèles classiques
sont en train de faire des trucs
augmentés pour les Happy H. les les 001
% qui prend ses payés, lui il donne le
pouvoir aux 95 % de gens qui n'ont pas.
Il est en train de le faire partout.
Est-ce que c'est pas c'est pas dangereux
de donner le pouvoir au 95 99 % juste le
pouvoir de bidouiller les machines que
tu achètes ? Juste ça. C'est-à-dire que
au lieu d'acheter un smartphone à 600 €
tu te le fabriques toi-même à 50 € et
s'il est en pein tu le répares. Je
trouve que ça c'est génial. Où est le
problème ? Pareil pour les drones et les
reurs. Donc si tu veux l'idée c'est de
dire par rapport à la question est-ce
qu'il est trop tard ? Moi je crois qu'au
contraire c'est le moment où jamais
parce que la génération des 18 35 ans
n'a jamais été aussi en contrôle des
outils numériques. Nous on n'est pas
très bon làdedans. Moi je suis pas très
bonne.
Tu es sûr qu'ils sont en contrôle ?
En tout cas ils savent je suis d'accord
avec toi, ils savent plus ou moins s'en
servir. Il faut du coup pour moi qu'il
sachent hacker la la machine matérielle
physique pour pouvoir changer les
batteries tout ça et tout ça. Puis fait
dans savoir ce qu'il y a dans le code et
ensuite apprendre le code. C'est comme
l'électricité elle sera partout. Donc
l'a demain il faut pas forcément savoir
coder mais comprendre ce que c'est que
l'IA. comprendre quelles sont les
données qui sont utilisées par les gars
femmes et autres pour savoir lesquels il
vaut mieux protéger. C'est comme mettre
une capote par rapport au sida quoi, tu
vois.
Ouais, c'est tu sais tu sais les gamins
maintenant ils oublient des fois de
mettre des capotes mais bon c'est
dommage.
Qu'est-ce que tu peux nous dire de la
fonction exponentielle ? Est-ce que ça
te parle ?
Euh oui, j'ai étudié ça quand j'étais à
l'école des mines, mais pour moi,
j'aimerais bien que ce soit au-delà de
l'exponentiel, c'est même exponentiel
plus+ plus que j'aimerais voir
maintenant avec les crapaux.
C'est-à-dire que mon idée c'est que un
crapau qui convainc 10 crapau et ainsi
de suite, ça peut aller très très vite
si ça part vraiment de ce qui est en
toi. Parce que quand tu cherches des
cordes de gens qui partagent vraiment
quelque chose qui t'est qui t'est
propre, des gens qui te ressemblent que
tu as toucher instantanément, ça peut
être des milliers tout de suite quand tu
prends les problématiques de de
souffrance comme l'autisme, l'asperger
ou dans le cas des borderline ou des
boulimiques, tu vois des choses qui
touchent vraiment les gens profondément
là où ils sont. Donc là, je parle pas
des du marketing et des des réclames et
cetera. Ces trucs-là sont peut-être
exponentiels. Moi ce que j'espère c'est
un truc viral qui est beaucoup plus gros
parce qu'il part des gens là où ils
sont. Et il suffit de voir quand quand
quelqu'un est désespéré d'un problème de
cancer ou de maladie autoimmune que
personne n'a résolu, quand tu trouves la
solution et que tu la fous sur le sur un
forum, ça fait tout de suite une tâche
d'huile. Tout le monde s'en empare parce
que c'est la survie quoi. C'est c'est
très important de partir de là où sont
les gens.
Est-ce que est-ce que tu as entendu
parler d'un documentaire de Harté qui
s'appelle Demain tous crétins ?
[rires]
Il faudra que j'aille le voir. Ça
ça parle de des perturbateurs
endocriniens qui influencent notre nos
capacités cognitives.
Ah ouais.
Et que les jeunes générations sont
exposé à un biotope qui est
dramatiquement pollué
et donc leur caution intellectuelle
baisse.
Ouais.
Donc quand tu me parles d'appréhender le
code, de démonter les smartphones,
est-ce que tu penses pas que ça risque
d'être compliqué si le quent
intellectuel de la masse baisse ? Pour
résumer trivialement, s'ils deviennent
de plus en plus abrutis, est-ce que tu
penses pas que les Happif vont se
régaler dans leur mégalomanie ?
Alors, heureusement pour nous, la chance
qu'on a c'est qu'on a pas besoin d'être
super intelligent pour faire une parade
à ce système-là. L'idée c'est que par
rapport à l'IA, pour prendre cet
exemple, pour se protéger par rapport à
cette question de big data et de ce que
les autres nous concoctent, euh la
singularité et cetera, on a pas besoin
d'avoir fait bac + 5. L'idée c'est que
c'est comme la carte bleue, si je je me
schématise, la carte bleue, tu sais
juste que tu as un code à quatre
chiffres. Bon, il faut retenir quatre
chiffres. Si même si tu es un peu
abruti, tu peux quand même y arriver. Et
surtout tu sais que si tu perds ta carte
bleue, tu dois appeler un numéro et ça
va déclencher l'arrêt de ta carte bleue
et puis tu as une assurance qui fait que
tu perds pas trop. Donc aujourd'hui la
carte bleue, il y a pas d'énormes
dégâts. Le risque zéro n'existe pas mais
il est géré socialement et par le
système. D'accord ? Il a c'est pareil,
il y a pas de risque zéro. Il y aura des
problèmes. Il y aura des gens qui vont
se faire malmener comme Amazon a malmen
mené des gens sur des zones les blacks
et cetera. On sait que les gens les
pauvres blacks dans les zones
métropolitaines étaient mal servies et
cetera. Donc des biais comme ça, il y en
aura plein. Par contre ce qu'il faut,
c'est plutôt que les gens soient
capables de détecter quand il y a un
truc qui est bizarre pour pouvoir
alerter un expert et dire attention il y
a un truc. Est-ce que vous pouvez nous
dire quoi ? Donc c'est vraiment un
système vraiment d'empowerment où tout
le monde peut un peu comme pour la carte
bleue avoir son système de sécurité et
comme Lia va être partout dans ton
téléphone, dans ta voiture et cetera, il
faut juste que les gens soient
conscients de quelles sont les données
qui sont en train de lâcher. Voilà,
c'est vraiment pas tellement plus
compliqué que ça. Donc faut pas non plus
diaboliser le truc. Donc je dirais que
par rapport aux abroutis, c'est pas
tellement là que je l'ai que je vois le
le risque. Il est pas tellement dans je
pense dans l'histoire de l'IA et de la
data. il est dans la carte électorale,
il est plutôt là. Effectivement pour
moi, c'est ce qui s'est passé pour Trump
et le fait que les élus aujourd'hui sont
réduits à faire une course de vitesse au
niveau médiatique pour gagner des votes.
Et donc celui qui a le contrôle des
médias, même avec des fakees, ce que
fait très bien Trump en mente, il ment
tellement plus vite que les autres que
de toute façon le temps que tu démontes
le truc, les gens ont déjà commencé à y
croire. Donc on est dans un système
complètement cancérigène et exponentiel
et c'est là que je trouve qu'il y a un
danger. Donc c'est c'est là où avec CDR
on avait ces discussions par rapport au
bouquin. Comment faire pour que le la
science soit rapide, suffisamment rapide
pour pouvoir contrer ce genre de
phénomène ? Et ça il y a pas de chemin
facile.
Rapide ou agile ?
Les deux. Et c'est ça qui est compliqué
parce que rapide on peut faire des
conneries. Agile bah qui définit qui est
le plus agile de l'autre et cetera, qui
est l'expert et cetera. il y a pas de
réponse, je pense qu'il faut pratiquer
et vraiment donner les clés en tout cas
à ce que des personnes qui se sont
capables de de de faire une
expérimentation puissent tester quit à
se planter et qu'on puisse en apprendre.
Pour moi, il faut ouvrir le truc, pas
laisser les experts tout seul décider
dans le divers ni voir mais faire que de
plus en plus les étudiants, les gens
dans la rue, t tous les gens qui se
posent une question aient une capacité à
interpeller le les experts pour leur
demander unic.
Voilà,
c'est pas c'est pas une c'est pas
recréer une société pyramidale ça.
Réclamer un expert. Disons que c'est pas
demander à l'expert de trancher, c'est
de dire sur un un sujet complexe comme
les vaccins ou d'autres qu'on puisse
dire voilà l'expert dis-moi juste
quelles sont les situations qui sont les
parties prenantes là-dedans. Il y a A B
C D E F qui pensent ceci. Voilà pourquoi
A dit ça, B dit ça et cetera. juste
objectiver les conditions du débat et
ensuite permettre aux gens de se faire
une opinion sur des bases réelles.
Aujourd'hui, on dit pas on donne pas aux
gens les éléments pour trancher. Donc on
leur pollue la tête avec quelques
slogans bien fichus et puis les gens du
coup au lieu de se faire un opinion vont
décider sur quelques trucs mal
je dirais mal justifié ou bancal ou ou
complet.
La décroissance ça fait ça te fait
penser à quoi ?
Un slogan.
Pourquoi ? Parce que je sais pas si dans
la nature on parle de décroissance, tu
vois,
on parle d'effondrement.
On parle d'effondrement aussi. Ça c'est
réel. Les les écosystèmes s'effondre.
La décroissance, c'est le slogan pour
caresser gentiment l'opinion publique et
pas leur faire peur.
Ouais. Moi la décroissance m'inquiète un
peu d'abord parce qu'il y a eu tout un
aspect un peu marketing à une époque qui
faisait peur aux gens. La décroissance,
ça faisait on aura plus d'électricité,
plus de chauffage, plus de viande et
cetera. Bon, c'était un peu réducteur
alors que c'était pas ce qu'il voulait
dire. C'était un peu comme le frugal.
Moi, je préfère parler de choses
positives qui amènent au même résultat.
Donc, par exemple, si on cherche quelque
chose de plus équitable, plus équilibré,
plus lent, peut-être plus humain,
peut-être qu'on arrivera à la même
chose. Donc en fait, la décroissance
dans un corps humain, si tu veux, tu as
des moments où tu crois puis un certain
moment c'est pas que tu décrois, c'est
que tu murriis et donc tu vas améliorer
certaines choses, certaines
fonctionnalités par exemple du corps.
Une courbe de gosse, ça te parle ?
La courb de gauche ça me parle. Oui,
parle-mois-en un peu.
Alors, la courbe de gosse, si tu veux,
c'est bah c'est une forme de cloche,
hein. C'est la forme qu'on tous les
phénomènes aléatoires dans la nature.
C'estàd qu'il y a une une le médiane, le
la norme, enfin le truc le plus
fréquent, c'est la le sommet de la la
courbe. Donc, c'est là là-dessus que tu
trouves le plus de gens qui sont sur ce
niveau-là. Ensuite, la courbe se
répartie et aux extrêmes, tu as le moins
de gens possible. Donc, c'est simplement
une courbe de distribution qui donne la
répartition des individus sur un critur
donné. On connaît bien celle du QI, elle
a été conçue comme telle. Donc au milieu
100, c'est le QI moyen de tout le monde.
Donc ça veut pas dire que tu
intelligent, c'est que tu as le QI moyen
de tout le monde. Et quand tu es dans
les extrêmes du côté positif là à
l'autre bout à 130 140, on dit que tu es
un HPI au potentiel. 130 140, c'est pas
les extrêmes, c'est c'est juste commence
à ça commence à descendre. Non
non, c'est tu mets à l'envers. C'est du
négatif côté 70 qu'on va dire que tu es
handicapé, que tu es débile mental,
grand retardé.
Grand retardé. Voilà. Alors qu'en
réalité euh le
HQI c'est où au ou
au potentiel intellectuel, ça se discute
parce que en gros les critères qu'il
prennent sont surtout les maths et euh
la langue, la grammaire et on sait très
bien qu'il y a d'autres intelligences
émotionnelles, kinesthésiques, spatial,
tout ce que tu veux. Donc moi, je
m'intéresse beaucoup plus aux
intelligences autres qui nous permettent
d'appréhender le monde différemment, tu
vois. Donc une goienne, tu peux
l'utiliser dans plein de choses, mais
c'est clair que l'intelligence se réduit
pas à une seule dimension.
Bon, revenons à la fonction
exponentielle. Madame desmines, euh
quand on voit la démographie augmentée
de faction de façon exponentiel,
l'épuisement des sols de façon
exponentielle, la consommation de viande
de façon exponentielle, la production
monétaire de façon exponentielle, la
consommation énergétique de façon
exponentielle et je pourrais qu'
continuer comme ça pendant 10 minutes.
Est-ce que c'est pas un peu utopique de
dire "Oui, on va donner le pouvoir à
tout le monde, on va bidouer dans tous
les sens, on va faire un grand mouvement
horizontal, tout va aller les gars."
C'est pas un peu C'est pas ton slogan à
toi et c'est pas ta façon de t'aveugler
?
Bah disons que face à un système qui va
dans le mur, je vois pas comment faire
que d'identifier les fous qui vont
commencer à faire autrement pour
commencer et ensuite d'essayer avec eux
de faire ta d'huile et de peser
suffisamment pour inverser le système
parce que les trucs du genre RSE ces
chosesl c'est bien gentil mais ça
caresse la girafe dans le même sens donc
au lieu qu'elle est qu'elle soit cette
hauteur ça peut-être un petit peu là
mais ça change pas frontiè moins la
courbe c'est faire moins mal la même
chose si tu veux et Margaret Mit disait
le changement commence toujours par
quelques fous. Euh et c'est peut-être là
où sont les crapaux fous, c'est
qu'aujourd'hui je vois pas comment on
peut inverser un système. Tu prends les
gars femmes par exemple, c'est pas eux
qui sont la solution. Ils vont continuer
à faire la même chose. Et le pire c'est
que les plus riches d'entre eux vont se
déburer
là où il faut, aller s'acheter des
terres en Nouvelle-Zélande et puis se
protéger leur vie dans le futur et puis
dans le pire des cas aller sur Mars et
cetera. Donc on voit bien que eux leur
solution c'est je m'en fous que tout le
monde se casse la gueule. L'exponentiel
c'est que je laisse les 99 9 % se
planter. Moi, je fais partie de 0 1 %
qui peuvent se payer ça. Donc pas grave,
moi je pars avec euh mes moyens
ailleurs. Et donc des gens comme David L
dont j'ai parlé tout à l'heure et les
utopiques peut-être qu'on est nous ou
François Tad typiquement, on postule que
c'est en essayant de donner la clé à
peut-être dans la courbe de gauche les
30 % débiles mentaux ou de l'autre côté
enfin les 3 % de chaque côté et en
essayant de les prendre parce qu'ils
sont différents de remonter la courbe
petit à petit pour passer de 3 % de TLM
à peut-être 10 % de d'autres choses et
ainsi de suite. Et petit à petit, si tu
fais 15 % par rapport à la masse, c'est
déjà mieux que 01 %. Donc c'est cette
idée que les crapoufous qui sont au bout
atypique du débile mental super
intelligent puisse commencer à faire
différent, recruter des cordes comme
eux, commencer à proposer des solutions
et commencer à faire tage ville pour
remonter. C'est vraiment le si tu lis le
rapport de France Atadine, il ne dit que
ça. Société apprenante, ça veut dire que
chacun peut être un apprenant sur ses
marottes à lui et partager et commencer
à bouger le public. Et après bon, il a
fait un gros travail pour essayer
d'aller jusqu'à l'institution,
l'éducation nationale et tout ça. Moi,
je me contente des gens qui sont comme
on va dire un peu comme lui les comme
David Lee, t tous les petits jeunes qui
ont fait de l'entreprise sociale et
solidaire, enfin des trucs comme ça.
Donc trouver des gens qui ont déjà
commencé à faire différents et commencé
à essayer de faire des des petites
cortes.
C'est beaucoup de courage tout ça, non ?
De toute façon, je je te dis moi les
gars femmes, cela dit, chez les gars
femmes, j'ai rencontré des gens dont les
enfants sont autistes et qui du coup me
disent "Ah mais j'ai envie de t'aider et
du coup si eux on peut les faire bouger,
ainsi de suite." Je dis pas que que la
clé c'est que dans le mal-être hein. Il
y a aussi des gens qui sont des artistes
qui s'intéressent à des choses belles et
qui voient d'autres choses.
Il y a quand même plus de gens à mon
avis qui sont peut-être en mesure de
faire le petit pas de côté et notamment
dans les grandes entreprises qui sont
pas que des grands méchants parce qu'ils
sont dans une grande boîte et qui sont
prêts à faire des expérimentations pour
essayer de voir si on peut commencer à
bouger un peu chez public.
En anglais, on dit step, c'est ça non ?
Oui, c'est ça. Un pas de côté.
Un pas de côté, ça veut dire aussi
choisir son camp, non ? Hm, ça peut être
ça mais pour moi le le camp clairement
il est pas dressé dans l'espèce de
bateau qui va dans le mur hein. C'est
clair. Moi, je me compare plutôt à Néo
et Matrix. Je préfère être Néo, même si
le vaisseau qu'il a, il est pas beau.
Ils sont plus que six dedans ou cinq, je
sais plus à la fin. Mais on va dire que
on est un peu dans cette situation là si
tu veux. Donc pour moi, mon camp c'est
le vaisseau. Mais je trouve important
d'être capable de passer de l'un à
l'autre tout le temps. Il faut pas
rester que dans l'un ou que dans
l'autre. Voilà. Et
tu te brûles passer de l'un à l'autre ?
Bah
tu perds pas des plumes.
Bah tu sais, j'ai je me suis beaucoup
brûlé quand j'étais dedans. Euh work,
boulimique, alcoolique, tout ça si tu
veux. Aujourd'hui, en étant dans mon
camp, là où je suis actuellement, ça va
beaucoup mieux parce que déjà, je
m'occupe de de ce qui compte pour moi.
J'ai l'impression que ça fait encore
plus de sens parce que c'est vraiment
centré sur mes propres expériences
personnelles et les solutions que j'ai
apporté.
Tu absoues ton âme,
pardon ? Tu absou ton âme.
J'absou mon âme. Bah, tu sais, je crois
pas en Dieu donc c'est un peu compliqué
de dire ça. Euh et encore moins surtout
pas aux religions. C'est ça que j'aime
pas trop le côté pyramidal des
religions. S'il y a des choses qui
m'intéressent, c'est plutôt le côté
conscience. J'aime pas le mot spirituel
mais la l'éveil des consciences qu'il y
a par exemple chez le dailama ou dans ce
genre de de de principes de de doctrine
dans la méditation, le yoga. Donc voilà,
c'est pas une religion d'ailleurs le
bouddhisme enfin tel que le pratique le
dailama. Donc pour moi, c'est plutôt le
la capacité à aller chercher en soi
d'aller plus loin dans l'alignement
entre, on va dire ce qu'on est
physiquement, voilà, ce qu'on est
là-dedans là. Et puis quelque part un
truc ici qui est le cœur, tu appelles ça
l'âme, peut-être que c'est l'âme mais
c'est ce principe qui fait qu'on peut
avoir de l'empathie ou la compassion
pour les autres.
Krishna Murti, ça te parle ?
Alors, je l'ai pas trop lu mais je vois.
Oui oui oui. Bah oui, c'est c'est tout à
fait ça. Oui.
Je peux pas en dire plus que je l'ai pas
lu, mais je sais qu'il parle de ces
questionslà de de l'âme effectivement de
cette partie-là la troisème.
Alors une question de la communauté euh
ça va prendre combien de temps de faire
ça pour interrogation ? On a le temps
pour l'interrogation.
Je ne sais pas combien de temps on a. On
démarre tout de suite d'abord et ensuite
on a pas le choix. Il faut de toute
façon aller chercher les crapaux fous
partout et puis il y en aura mieux ça
ira parce que de toute façon je je ne
vois que des fous qui sont capables de
sortir de ce système. C'est c'est
vraiment l'histoire de la matrice. Ce
système va dans le mur. Si on continue à
laisser les choses aller comme ça avec
les gars femmes et tout ça et c'est même
pas qu'il soi pourri les gens qui sont
là-dedans. C'est que ils ont un tel
pouvoir que la bagarre de l'IA pour
l'instant on l'a perdu. Pour la partie
front office, la partie donnée, on l'a
perdu. Donc ce que dit aussi le rapport
de Vilani, c'est que la seule manière
qu'on a de ralentir ça, c'est de
s'attaquer à Alia façon éthique contrôle
les données et donc réintroduire
l'usager là-dedans. Donc ça tombe bien
parce que c'est le discours des
crapaufous. Il faut que les gens
comprennent ce que c'est qu'une donnée
et en quoi c'est important. Une fois
qu'on a pigé ça et qu'on sait qu'on peut
les rapatrier, qu'on peut faire des
choses protéger et cetera, on va
commencer à faire à faire chier un peu
les gars femmes comme en 2002, on
faisait chier Monsanto et et les grandes
boîtes.
On on les fait pas trop chier là en ce
moment. Non, mais il va falloir le faire
et je pense qu'ils sont pas forcément
les pires. Il y a les Chinois qui font
des choses encore plus dramatiques en
terme de de repérage des bons citoyens,
des mauvais citoyens et cetera hein.
Donc
comment comment on le sait mais on va te
laisser l'expliquer comment ils font
pour
B. Ils sont en train de de prendre le
big data pour dire celui-là est un bon
citoyen, celui-là n'est pas un bon
citoyen, celui-là il a le droit de se
marier, celui-là il a pas le droit et
cetera et cetera. Donc
ça tue les crapau fous.
Pardon ? Ça tue les crapau fous, ça les
standardise.
Il y en a là-bas mais je sais pas
comment ils vont faire pour euh si en
fait en même temps d'habilite un crapau
fou tu vois il tient le chenzen
quel âge il a
il a il a bon âge hein
ouais 50 piges quoi.
Ouais c'est ça. Ouais mais ce qu'il est
en train de faire derrière c'est
remarquable hein.
Tu as toujours traversé dans les clous
lui
toi ?
Moi tu plaisantes ?
Ouais imagine de repasser ton enfance en
Chine là maintenant.
Toujours traverser dans les clous, avoir
des bons points. On aurait pu. On en on
serait pas tombé sur toi.
Ah, tu veux dire
si tu avais été standardisé dans ta tête
?
Bah, j'ai traversé les clous
effectivement. Enfin, non, même pas.
Même quand je faisais l'école des mines,
j'étais toujours à la soonne à écouter.
J'étais à côté à écouter Bourdieux et
cetera. J'étais j'ai jamais fait ce
qu'on me demandait de faire. Et même à
l'école des mines, je faisais peut-être
10 % de montant sur les matières
d'ingénieur qui m'emmerdaient et 90 %
sur l'économie et d'autres trucs. Mais
j'ai traversé les clous. Tu veux dire,
je suis sorti du passage cûté.
Non, tu aurais eu une mauvaise note par
le système de notation chinoise.
Ah ouais. Tu aurais été cassé depuis le
départ et tu aurais pas pu. Est-ce que
la standardisation des comportements va
nous tuer ?
Elle va tuer l'humain. Ouais. Si on la
laisse se faire, c'est tous les humains
seront pareils. On sera tous pareils
avec la même tronche et les mêmes
envies. C'est c'est juste pas c'est
inacceptable. Je n'imagine même pas que
ça puisse arriver.
C'est clair arrivé.
Bah non, parce que tu vois bien, il y a
des gens comme toi qui font une radio
intéressante, enfin une une émission de
broadcasting intéressante. Il y a des il
y a des fous toujours. Heureusement, moi
ce que je pense plutôt, c'est que en
réalité, si tu regardes ça à l'échelle
de 4 milliards et demi et la petite
espèce qu'on est,
on est une team
hein.
On est une team.
Une team ? Ouais. Pardon. Pardon pour
les autres. Euh moi ce que je pense
c'est qu'en fait par rapport au 99,
alors on va dire il y a les 01 % qui
sont en train de piquer tout le mago et
d'essayer de partir avec la cassette.
Est-ce que c'est pas en fait la la
notre destinée d'humanité, c'est-à-dire
d'élever
euh 0,01 % de super mégalau, super
surdoués qui vont pouvoir coloniser
d'autres
d'autres endroits euh dans le système
solaire ou ailleurs et laisser la plebe
crever dans la pollution. Justement, je
crois pas. C'est là où ma salle
intertitude, c'est sur le volant.
Fait l'avocat du diable. Oui, bien sûr,
mais j'aime bien cette idée parce qu'en
fait ça me fait penser à l'extinction
des espèces et tout ce qu'on est en
train de réfléchir sur le niveau de
conscience qui arrive et moi, je pense
que le le volant de gens, au-delà de ces
0 1 % qui sont TPMG, tout pour ma
gueule, tu as derrière un volant de
gens, je sais pas si c'est 1 %, 10 % ou
30 %. Et moi l'hypothèse que j'ai c'est
que c'est au moins 1 % et que c'est
peut-être j'espère au moins 15 à 30 % si
on s'y prend bien avec ces méthodes du
crapau qui fait des cortes. Ces gens-là
c'est TDI euh le le dai Lama c'est tous
les gens dans les crapaufous que j'ai
mis dans le bouquin les jeunes là de
ticket for change et tout ça. Donc c'est
des gens qui ont une compétence et qui
veulent bien faire et qui veulent pas
justement faire tes PMG. Ce qui nous
distingue des autres c'est une
compétence et la volonté de partager. Et
euh j'ai j'ai plus de mal à dire Cédric
Villanier à cause du fait qu'il est
maintenant chez Macron. Mais avant je
leurais dit spontanément parce que je le
connais en tant qu'humain par rapport à
ce qu'on a fait ensemble sur les
handicapés et cetera. Donc il y a plein
de gens de bien et dans les crapaux
maintenant j'en ai j'en ai 350 presque
un millier qui sont très actifs. C'est
tous des gens de bien qui ont cette
notion d'éthique et de partage et qui
ont des compétences. Donc si ces
gens-là, mon hypothèse c'est que si les
autres décolent vers Mars et cetera ou
même qui restent ici, ils seront de
toute façon dans un ghetto, ils seront
pas à mon avis très heureux dans leur
vie quelque part. Ça peut pas suffire de
vivre dans la coque. Il y a la coque qui
est les [__]
Il y a la coque qui est des [__]
Ouais. Voilà. Donc ils vivont dans le
paradise artificiel mais je pense pas
que ce soit l'humanité dont on est en
vie. Moi, je suis intéressé par le
volant suivant qui est justement
partageux et qui est visionnaire dans
lequel le Dail Lama qui je te disais
avec le avec David Lee, ils ont installé
un un maker space dans une un monastère
qui dépend de Dalil Lama à sa demande
pour que les moines, les orphelins et
les enfants là-bas qui sont très pauvres
apprennent Lia. Ils sont en train de
bidouiller des trucs pour comprendre
l'IA et faire du code. Donc tu as des
machins complètement modernes dans un
monstre tout pourri là dans le nord de
l'Inde. Donc on va aller le voir cet
hiver quand on va aller voir Dalil Lama.
Mais c'est pour te dire que ce mec-là,
il a déjà anticipé tout ça. Il il a vu
tout ça. Ça fait 20 ans qu'il dit qu'il
faut que les scientifiques viennent en
aide à la société pour faire comprendre
que les croyances qu'on les occidentaux
sont pas bonnes et qu'il faut absolument
que les occidentaux se réveillent. C'est
vraiment le dormeur doit se réveiller.
Et [grognement] ça fait 20 ans qu'avec
le Man and Life Institute avec
comment il s'appelle ? Varelli non
Varella Fran France ou Varella, je crois
que c'est ça Paloelto tout ça Manella
Fite. Ils ont vraiment commencer à
bosser sur les neurosciences pour que
les scientifiques viennent confirmer ce
que disait le daily lama. C'est quand
même étonnant tu as des dialogues avec
des moines qui se foutent des électrodes
sur la tête pour prouver que quand ils
méditent, il se passe que ce qu'ils
disent tu vois. Donc ces choses-là
existent depuis 20 ans. Et donc ce que
je veux dire par là, c'est que des gens
éclairés comme ça qui ont vu qu'il
fallait vraiment aller vers la
l'ouverture des consciences, la
compassion, le partage et tout. Bah je
je suis pas seul à le dire. Le dayama
même le pape avec son laissi je crois
que ça s'appelle ce genre de choses. Ils
ont ils ont ils ont vu des trucs et moi
qui suis totalement hâté qui ne croient
pas aux religion constate quand même que
ces gens-là ont vu des trucs. Ensuite je
vois tous mes copains dans les grandes
corporettes, les gens qui sont dans des
mouvements peut-être un peu plus avancés
du côté les Mathieu Baudin des gens
comme ça. Donc c'est l'institut des
futurs souhaitables et tout ça. On peut
dire vivrait. Bon, il y a plein de gens,
hein.
Est-ce que Est-ce que tu juges ceux qui
ne pensent pas comme toi ?
Euh non, je en fait je déjà je préfère
éviter de juger parce que je sais que je
peux me tromper. Euh que je sois pas
d'accord, bah je me dis OK, c'est son
point de vue de là où il est avec son
vécu. Tu sais quand tu sors de d'une
pathologie lourde, tu sais très bien que
quand tu es dans un certain truc euh tu
vois les choses de ta façon. Donc on
comprend que c'est un package. Moi je
pars du principe que tout le monde a son
package à traîner. Donc je préfère pas
juger la personne mais essayer de
comprendre comment le retourner par
rapport à sa vision pour que ça puisse
aller mieux pour lui et puis qu'il
m'emmerde de moins en passage. Quand on
m'emmerde trop en général je cherche pas
à contrer. J'essaie d'accélérer. C'est
un truc que Mose m'avait appris. Quand
les gens t'emmerdent et c'est pas leur
prouver qu'ils ont tort juste accélère.
J'ai toujours fait ça. Donc c'est pour
ça je suis restais toujours au frontière
de l'innovation. Chaque fois quelqu'un
me faisait chier, voulait me piquer mon
bébé, genre le sais, j'allais faire
autre chose. Du coup, bah ça ça
polliniait vachement plus. Je me suis
jamais retouvant en situation de
défendre un bébé parce qu'au contraire,
si on me le prend, je suis contente. Ça
veut dire qu'il a il a réussi. Donc ma
liberté c'est
compos tu composes avec les cons, c'est
ça ?
Euh ouais. Non, je compose pas. Non. Si
les cons m'emmerdent, je préfère voir
est-ce que j'ai vraiment si je peux me
défendre que c'est léger, je le fais.
Mais en général, j'ai même pas besoin.
J'accélère.
Est-ce que tu attaques ?
Non. J'attaque pas, je vais toujours
plus vite, j'essaie d'aller plus haut
toujours. C'est toujours ça que je fais
même dans ma vie quotidienne, j'adore
monter très haut à 5000 6000 m à pâte et
puis en ce moment, je fais de l'apnée
profonde. Ça aussi c'est un truc qui est
comme la méditation. Pour l'instant, je
suis à 45 m en selon du fil. Et
euh non, pas pas la gueuse. Enfin, si tu
as raison à la gueuse. À la gueuse 45 et
en palme en poids constant, je suis à un
peu moins de 40.
Donc ça aussi c'est un truc, j'ai
toujours besoin d'aller d'aller voir les
frontières et tu vois quand tu montes à
5000 m
extrême. Ouais. Personne te le pique,
c'est toi qui l'a fait avec tes pattes.
Est-ce que est-ce qu'on te dit tout le
temps que tu es extrême ?
Euh
j'ai entendu pas mal de choses mais pas
pas ce mot-là. On m'a souvent dit que
j'étais très agitée ou non pas comme en
gon dit plutôt aujourd'hui plutôt
inspirante que je parle très vite. Euh
je dirais que tu es normal.
Ah bah c'est sympa, ça me fait plaisir.
C'est marrant ça. On m'a jamais dit ça.
On m'a plutôt dit que j'étais atypique,
étonnante. Pour certains, je pense que
je les ai gêné parce que à l'époque en
2002, j'ai j'ai effectivement peut-être
un peu attaqué. Au début quand je
commençais à comprendre tout ça, avant
que je rencontre Mose, en fait, j'avais
tendance trop à à défendre mon turf en
disant mais il a tort. Donc dans les ONG
en question, j'ai peut-être fait des
dégâts à certains moments parce que je
savais que j'avais raison et dire j'ai
eu raison plus tard mais à l'époque je
leur disais vous êtes vous êtes con de
vous battre pour telle petite bestiole
attaquez-vous au mode de vie des gens
aidez-les à vivre mieux et ils
s'intéresseront au bestioles après.
Enfin un truc comme ça et ça a été mal
reçu typique. Mais aujourd'hui je fais
plus ça aujourd'hui. Quand je suis
convaincu que j'ai raison je l'écris,
j'en fais un manifeste, je le partage
avec les gens qui veulent l'entendre. Si
les gens me suivent et on est peut-être
que de tr sur 10 mais je sais qu'on est
dans la bonne configuration. Comment tu
gères la frustration ?
H
d'abord, je réfléchis pourquoi est-ce
que ça me frustre ? Est-ce que je suis
en colère ? Est-ce que j'ai peur ?
Qu'est-ce qui se passe vraiment en moi ?
Et si la frustration c'est
parce que j'ai le sentiment que c'est
injuste, bah soit par exemple enfin, il
y a plein de réponses mais pour faire
court euh on peut être frustré parce
qu'on a l'impression qu'on pourrait
faire plus et que c'est pas juste ou que
c'est pas c'est pas c'est pas idéal. et
on a envie de donner plus à la situation
auquel cas c'est par rapport à quelque
chose qui est extérieur. Il y a un
deuxième cas qui peut de gérer en soi un
truc sur euh merde, j'ai pas été reconnu
machin tout ça. Ça c'est un problème
d'ego. Ça c'est le plus facile à virer.
Donc euh ça en général j'ai pas cette
frustration là. Même si parfois je me
dis euh fait chier l'autre il a il a
vraiment pourri la réunion et s'il avait
un peu moins ouvert sa gueule, ça aurait
été mieux. Mais bon c'est pas c'est pas
très grave. Moi maintenant je suis assez
zine je laisse pisser comme quand je
suis en en apné à 45 m. Tu vois tu as
pas tu as pas les moyens de de
t'énerver. tu dois vraiment te calmer
pour aller jusqu'au fond. La seconde le
second cas, c'est quand je vois qu'il
une réunion ou un truc a été foiré parce
que des gens ont on poler le le
processus. Dans ce cas-là, je vais quand
même essayer de redresser le tir après
coup. Je vais voir s'il y a d'autres
personnes qui partagent ce sentiment et
ensemble on va faire une petite corte
pour essayer de rasser le truc. Voilà,
ça ça m'arrive de temps en temps de de
faire ce travail après coup pour essayer
de réparer ou de de faire mieux.
Qu'est-ce que tu penses des mouvements
anarchistes ? Ah ben
moi j'aime bien en fait bah les cœurs,
c'est de l'anarchie.
En fait, on a peur de ce terme parce que
anarchie ça peut donner l'impression du
tout n'importe quoi.
Tu sais pourquoi ça donne peur ?
À cause on fait l'amour dans la rue, je
sais pas quoi.
Non non non, c'est qu'on a consciemment
fait une stratégie délibérée pour faire
passer les anarchistes pour des gens
dangereux.
Ah ouais. Ah ça je savais pas. Je
pensais que c'était dans l'inconscient
collectif. Alors qu'en fait les anards
pour moi un anarchie c'est quelqu'un qui
veut pas d'une pyramide, c'est quelqu'un
qui veut avoir la possibilité de
s'organiser librement. Si tu prends le
l'entreprise libérée de Frédéric Lelou,
il dit que ça. Il y a que trois critères
pour l'entreprise vraiment de demain. Le
premier c'est l'autoorganisation,
c'est de l'anarchie. Le deuxième c'est
le wholess, l'intégrité. C'est ce que je
viens de raconter depuis tout à l'heure
sur soigner d'abord ses failles partir
de ça pour ensuite aller vers les
autres. Et le troisième, c'est le
evolutionary purpose, c'est-à-dire le
but qui est tout le temps mobile. Et si
tu es dans un environnement qui bouge
tout le temps, tu peux pas juste avoir
comme seule ligne de but le truc là-bas.
tu ajustes le tir forcément comme quand
tu fais du vélo. Quand tu prends ces
trois principes, c'est les clés de
l'anarchie
en fait. Enfin à mes yeux hein. Alors
après ça dépend une énergie mal
contrôlée qui sert à rien. Euh il y en a
aussi hein, je je pense hein. Mais dans
les principes mêmes de l'organisation
qui est complètement libre, qui laisse à
chacun la possibilité de
s'autodéterminer en restant intègre avec
lui-même qui est le deuxième point et
qui s'adapte en fonction de ce qui se
passe autour. La sagesse chiloise ne
parle que de ça, hein. [soupir]
Le c'est le confusianisme, c'est ça ?
Non, c'est plus précisément une pensée
plus proche de La
mec qui écrit très bien ça, c'est Claude
Julien dans un livre que je te
recommande qui s'appelle Un sage et sans
idée. Et dans ce livre là, il décortique
la pensée ancienne des Chinois en disant
voilà le sage ne parle pas de de
résilience, il parle pas de de juste ou
de vérité, il parle de congruence.
congruence à chaque instant le sage et
sans idée, il arrive comme ça et puis il
s'adapte, il trouve la meilleure
solution par rapport à ce qui se passe
devant lui. Et il dit il y a pas de
bien, de juste ou de faux, il y a que un
continuum et le le le sage en fait, il
explore les extrêmes pour trouver le
juste milieu. Donc pour eux la notion,
il s'adapte instantanément à ce qui se
passe. Il
il arrive en tout cas à essayer de faire
la part des choses et donc eux ils se
marent un peu avec notre philosophie qui
est très
pour contre, antithèse et puis les trucs
très carrés quoi. Pour eux c'est le
monde est pas comme ça. Ils sont
beaucoup plus pragmatiques.
Si je te dis s rendipité.
C'est rendipité. Ah bah c'est le cœur
des crapaux. Quelqu'un m'a récemment
fait une remarque que j'ai trouvé assez
sympa. Il m'a dit "En fait les crapau
fous vous êtes un espace ou une fabrique
a créé la sérendipité." Parce que nous
ce qu'on dit aux gens c'est il y a trois
tsunamis donc sortez du TLM et venez
nous voir. On va essayer de changer de
phase. Deuxièmement, venez avec vos
différence, vos pêtes au casque, vos
failles. On vous prend tel que vous êtes
et on veut juste vous aider à faire un
pas de côté par rapport à ce truc qui
vous titille et ensuite vous allez
rencontrer d'autres personnes comme
vous. Et du coup la personne qui ose
parler de son petit truc, le chef
d'entreprise de son fils autiste et
cetera, il fait ce petit pas de côté et
ainsi de suite. Et du coup, on va lui
faire rencontrer des gens comme lui sur
cette thématique là. Et donc là ça fait
la sérentipité. Après les gens en
général après une réunion crapau qui a
bien marché, ils disent "Ah voilà, je
pensais pas qu'it votant comme moi. Ah
dis donc, je pensais pas que je pouvais
connecter avec un tel. Puis après, je
connecte un tel avec un tel parce que du
coup dans mes crapaux, il y en a un peu
partout, il y a plein de thématiques. Je
leur dis tiens, j'ai un tel là-bas, un
tel là. Donc moi, j'accélère les
connexions. Donc c'est une fabrique
assez rendipitée.
Est-ce que tu parles après on va passer
aux questions internet. Euh est-ce que
le fait d'accélérer
tout le temps ou de connecter plus vite
que les autres, ça ne te crée pas
énormément de solitude que tu combles
avec tes petites réunions de crapau fou
et des choses comme ça ? Mais
réellement, [raclement de gorge] est-ce
que
cette solitude
ne ne te ralentit pas ?
Une très bonne question. La réponse
c'est si bien sûr. Je pense que le truc
c'est que dans une vie antérieure avant
peut-être le crapau, j'ai toujours couru
en tête toute seule. En tout cas,
j'ouvrais des tas de portes et souvent
j'ai pas fait attention au followership.
Et on sait que le deuxième qui court qui
est tout nu sur la pelouse là, c'est cel
qui compte le plus. Et et du coup euh
peut-être qu'à l'époque j'ai limité mon
potentiel d'impact parce que j'ai pas
fait attention à ça. Maintenant avec les
crapaux, il se trouve que par chance et
aussi parce que ma vie a évolué donc je
fais un peu plus attention à ça. J'ai 50
bales maintenant tu vois euh j'ai la
chance d'avoir des followers justement
comme ce gars sur la pelouse qui
commence à se rémousser puis les autres
qui le qui le suivent. Des gens qui me
suivent et qui ont vraiment ça dans leur
trip. J'en ai un euh si vois ces vidéos
qui se reconnaîtra Christian qui a 55 ou
plus. et qui est vraiment typiquement
formaté pour ça. Et lui c'est un c'est
un bonheur, il adore faire ça. Il a une
vision, il a été consultant,
communication, il a fait plein de
choses. Il a aussi une une vie très très
pleine. C'est tous des gens qui ont des
vécus de ouf hein. Et du coup lui il
fait ça, il va me chercher les gens.
Des vécus de ouf, c'est ça ?
Ouais. Ouais. Des vécus de ouf. Ouais.
Et et du coup lui
peur ça non ?
Bah en même temps, c'est ça qui est
génial. il me dit je avec les crapau à
je veux dédier mon temps à ça il le fait
bénévolement alors que il peut vraiment
toucher des grands chefs d'entreprise et
il m'apporte ce suivi cette ce rodage
cette rondeur qui fait que les gens
suivent donc c'est avec lui qu'on va
faire le truc à Lille le 5 et le 6 juin
on va faire un très gros truc avec
l'université là-bas il y aura beaucoup
de grandes entreprises voilà bon chez NG
j'en ai parlé tout à l'heure j'ai une
une fille formidable qui s'appelle
Valéri pareil c'est ce qu'elle fait elle
entraîne les gens elle les emmènent du
coup je suis beaucoup moins seul et
c'est elle qui va ramener des cortes
là-bas et je peux en donner plein
d'autres noms que je les cite tous mais
je pense à Catherine ma thérapeute
préférée du côté des borderline sur les
problèmes de troubles alimentaire fait
un travail énorme. Ça fait 35 ans
qu'elle fait ça. Elle aide des milliers
de de femmes et de gens en difficulté
avec c ces choses-là. Bon et voilà des
gens remarquables qui du coup se sont
regroupés un petit peu autour des
crapaufous et je me sens aujourd'hui
beaucoup moins seule que je n'ai jamais
été. Ce qui n'empêche pas quand même
qu'aujourd'hui je suis un peu quand même
très stretché parce que là j'ai des
cordes partout hein. Donc je passe mon
temps entre internet de répondre aux
gens. Donc je pense que les crapau vont
bouger, vont passer un un seuil et qu'on
va essayer de recruter plus de gens
comme Christian, Valérie,
Asma, Antoine, Antoine Brachet des
barbares, tous ces gens qui font tout le
suivi qui qui accompagnent derrière.
Question d'internet, l'école fait partie
du problème de crétinisation point
d'interrogation.
Est-ce que le système éducatif, il faut
pas apprendre au gamin à à à à survivre
à ce système éducatif plutôt que à la
quiessé ?
Complètement. Et d'ailleurs, si tu
regardes bien la société apprenante,
François Tad était le premier à
bousculer l'école en disant son premier
tê talk, c'était "Je supporte plus
l'école depuis que ils ont essayé de
raboter mon gamin." Et c'est depuis 15
ans qu'il s'est mis en tête de changer
l'école. Donc lui, il s'est attaqué au
mammouth. Il a décidé de faire ce
rapport. il paye beaucoup de sa vie pour
faire tout ça, hein. Donc lui, il
s'attaque au gros machin pour essayer de
le rendre un peu moins euh effectivement
chrétinisant. Mais après, c'est pas que
les les profs ou les gens soient
crétins, c'est un système c'est lourd à
changer. Et donc, on fait des normes
avec les goosiennes et les gamins
trouvent pas leur place dans un système
trop normatif. Ça c'est le problème.
Mais tu changes pas du jour au lendemain
un truc qui a été terrorisé à une telle
échelle. Donc, on peut faire deux
choses. D'une part, faire ce que fait
François pour essayer d'avoir des
alternatives à côté et progressivement
les faire monter en puissance. et de
l'autre aider les enfants à moins
souffrir de ça en les équipant
effectivement pour répondre à minima que
la chose leur demande. Moi je l'ai fait
à l'école donc j'étais toujours première
en classe. Bon ben tu tu bosses et tu
fais le truc c'est chiant mais il faut
faire un minimum pour passer la barre je
dirais si on peut voilà et peut-être
protéger ses enfants pour pas devenir
crétin et complètement
tu sais
racorner sur les bords et couper un
petit morceau pour rentrer dans le
système. Est-ce que si la masse de
résignation de la plebe,
si c si cette masse de résignation est
plus importante que cette douce utopie
que sont les crapaufous, qu'est-ce que
ça va donner ?
Bah ça va donner des gens qui vont euh
si tu tires leur extrême, c'est c'est
Black Mirror. Il suffit de voir cette
vidéo, ce film-là et tu dis voilà, ça
c'est le monde de demain. C'est à peu
près ça. Et si c'est pas ça qui se passe
avec Antoin de Bracher et ils ont monté
euh Bright Mirror qui est l'inverse où
c'est des gens qui racontent des
comptes. On essaie de faire un truc
positif et avec l'université à Lille, on
va essayer de faire des vidéos courtes,
des tas de petites captations avec un
crapau dessus pour montrer qu'il y a une
alternative positive. Et moi ce que j'ai
vu c'est que si je fais un parallèle
avec le l'écologie et le bio dans les
années 2000 à l'époque quand on a
commencé en 2000 avec Philippe Desbros,
Pierre Raby, Nicolas Ho à l'époque avec
qui j'ai déjà fait mon premier bouquin à
l'époque euh
ça parfait hein.
Ouais, il était euh
il était lui très très je pense qu'il
est encore aujourd'hui mais lui il est
dans la machine maintenant. Mais il
était très très remonté. Il il y avait
des vrais combats quoi. Tu vois,
il est dans la machine. J'aime bien.
Comment tu as fait pardon ? Bah ouais,
malheureusement hein. Tu moi je
franchement je voudrais jamais faire de
la politique
parce que tu passes ton temps à gérer
les lourdeurs et tout ce que tu dois
avaler. À mon avis, c'est juste
impossible.
Et la politique avec une hache ?
Quoi ?
La politique avec une hache.
Ouais. Alors ça je sais pas faire non
plus.
La politique avec une guillotine,
qu'est-ce que tu en penses ?
Bah la politique avec une guillotine,
on a tu as pas beaucoup entendu parler
de violence ou de sélection des
mouvements violents pour faire changer
les choses ou secouer les choses. C'est
pas dans ma nature. La violence c'est
pas dans mon truc. Non non. La violence
et la force des faibles et s'arrête ou
non non commence ou s'arrête les
connaissances.
Je sais pas trop mais moi la violence me
gêne parce que d'abord on peut toujours
se tromper [grognement] et toutes les
guerres si tu regardes bien sont assis
sur des gens qui pensaient faire le bien
pratiquement toujours.
Ça c'est ce qu'on raconte aux petits
enfants avant de s'endormir hein.
Quand même si on regarde les guerres
religion les guer Ouais ouais toutes les
guerres de la religion toutes les
guerres c'est pognon ressources. Oui oui
bien sûr
le reste c'est le papier cadeau.
Hm bien sûr. Mais tu vois bien que
derrière il y avait un message
enoctrinant. Nous on est les bons. Il y
a les mécrans l'autre côté donc tous ces
discours le bon tu vois.
Donc moi je trouve que c'est assez
tendancieux. En tout cas la violence
fait pas partie de mes trucs. Mais euh
j'étais sorti de questions que tu posais
sur euh Black Mirror versus Bright
Mirror. Est-ce qu'on va y arriver ou pas
? Et quand même à l'époque dans les
années 2000 quand je m'étais engagé sur
les histoires d'écologie les bios tout
ça on n croyait pas. On était genre le
les parts de marché microscopique, un
surcoup à l'achat énorme quoi.
Aujourd'hui, presque tout le monde
achète du bio parce que c'est pas si
cher maintenant qu'on a fait basculer
les 15 % et à partir de là, on commence
à voir progressivement une montée en
puissance des voilà donc c'est possible
d'inverser quand même les choses.
J'ai bien aimé ton effet de manche sur
balayer la la violence. Tu tu dis que
les crapaufous c'est un spectre très
large que [raclement de gorge] tu prends
les gens bordur est-ce que tu prends
aussi les gens bordur qui pensent avec
une stratégie plus agressive, plus
pénétrante, plus ciblée ?
Ben, j'en ai pas rencontré en tout cas
qui en tout cas dès qu'il y a une
violence de type physique et même
verbal.
Non, mais la violence physique ne sert à
rien parce que les blessures guérissent.
Hm.
La violence psychique
H
Qu'est-ce que tu en penses ?
Ben, j'en ai pas rencontré. Euh, tu sais
pourquoi ? Parce que je crois que dans
l'histoire de la séripité et dans la
manière de faire des crapaux, on
privilégie vraiment l'intelligence
collective. Donc dans un groupe, dès que
j'ai quelqu'un qui prend la parole tout
le temps, il y en a eu un ou deux qui
dans la mar virtuelle sont rentrés sur
le rocket chat, ils ont commencé à
polluer, on les a viré. Là, j'ai été
entre guillemets violente. Mais si tu
veux, comme le principe de base pour
nous, c'est le le pas de côté positif,
le don vers l'autre et que par
conséquent, on est dans une intelligence
collective,
on n pas de gens qui sont venus pour
essayer de saboter le truc. C'est comme
Wikipédia en fait. Dans Wikipédia, les
gens qui ont essayé de saboter des pages
se sont vite fait sortir. Donc c'est le
même principe. Donc c'est pour ça qu'il
y a pas de violence,
ce qui n'est pas plus mal.
Bah ouais, heureusement. Ouais.
Autre question d'internet. Le GDPR
va-t-elle nous protéger ?
Donc la RGPD.
Ouais. La RGPD.
Euh bah c'est c'est une double réponse
en en premier lieu. Ça va quand même
nous mettre un un gourdin sur les GAFAM.
En plus, on a une espèce de rootfiler à
la Commission européenne qui hésite pas
à monter au créneau. Donc ça c'est bien.
Donc simplement, elle a un gourdin pour
faire taper sur les gafas et les autres
boîtes qui respecteraiit pas les règles.
Donc ça c'est un premier truc qui peut
quand même aider. La seconde c'est que
ça suffira évidemment pas puisque
derrière les gens vont se dire mais
qu'est-ce que je fais de ces données ?
D'abord est-ce que l'oubli il est total
? On peut pas vraiment dire que ça sera
forcément total. Il y a forcément
quelque part des données qui vont rester
quelque part. Ensuite, il y a des gens
qui vont pas pouvoir se passer de
Facebook ou de je sais pas tout quoi
alors qu'il y a Framasoft, il y a Lilo,
il y a plein de choses qui existent
hein. Donc les alternatives existe mais
il faut que les gens changent de
comportement. Donc c'est comme
l'histoire de la capote où touche pas à
mon pote ou de la chasse au gaspie.
C'est là où les crapau à mon avis ont un
rôle à jouer. C'est dire aux gens viens
on va jouer un petit peu, on va te
montrer le RGPD de manière ludique. Donc
à Marseille on va faire des acatons du
30 mai jusqu'au 2 juins. On va
expérimenter le truc et on va mettre des
gens en situation de jouer avec des
machines, de faire un peu de un mé qui
joue au pingpong. et cetera, des trucs
comme ça, comprendre ce que c'est que le
code, l'algorithme. Bon voilà, je pense
qu'il faut vraiment faire des ateliers
comme la main à la pâte que tout le
monde puisse aller jouer au coin de chez
soi pour comprendre ces trucs-là quoi.
Autre question d'internet, si le t-
combats plus importants que les autres,
sinon
c'est prioritaire.
Lequel est prioritaire ? Euh
pour moi, c'est celui de la différence,
c'est d'accepter la différence, tu vois.
Euh je crois que le reste viendra. C'est
que si on accepte qu'on peut parler à
quelqu'un qui a l'air bizarre, qui est
un peu différent, ça veut dire qu'on
peut aussi accepter que soi-même on a
des petits pê au casque. Ce travail
intérieur, c'est le premier truc. Donc
du coup, on est plus humble, on est plus
dans une posture d'intelligence
collective et de d'écouter et d'aller
vers l'autre. Après, bah tu as les trois
tsunamis. Donc, je sais pas si
l'écologie, la mise information et le
fake news,
la finance,
la finance pour moi c'est un problème
qui résulte du reste parce qu'en fait
qui va peut-être être déclencheur.
Ah oui, si ça se casse la gueule.
Évidemment, si une crise financière, bah
tout va se casser la gueule. Mais comme
d'habitude,
les gars de HC, ça va, ils sont sous
Xanax, sous Prosac. Qu'est-ce qu'ils
font
les gars de HC ? Tu sais euh cocaïne,
il se bourent toujours autant la gueule.
Non,
euh ça ça dépend de qui tu parles là. Je
sais, il y a toute une fraction de gens
que je fréquente pas du tout, ceux qui
veulent juste faire de la stratégie, du
business et cetera comme tous les
autres. Moi je je me suis intéressé aux
10 % de fêé qui veulent détourner la
finance et tout le reste pour faire les
choses utiles. Et donc si tu veux la
finance, c'est clair qu'il y aura ttô ou
tard un rattrapage économique ou
financier, une crise et tout ça. Comme
ça coûte à chaussée,
pardon.
Combien ça coûte à chausser ?
Bouf alors je sais pas, je crois que
c'est
50000 € je sais pas si c'est plus.
Je sais même pas. Je sais qu'en tout cas
les les jeunes que j'ai eu souvent on
empruntaient des sommes de cet ordre là.
Après exactement je sais pas combien
mais c'est c'est sûr que c'est cher.
Combien tu gagnes là ? Moi zéro,
tu gagnes zéro. Tu vis comment ?
Ah moi ça fait depuis que je suis passé
en ONG que je vis uniquement de ce que
j'ai eu avant. Et même quand je monte
j'avais le choix entre être président de
bénévole de mon assaut ou être
directrice générale salarié. Et être
salarié ça veut dire j'avais un CA
au-dessus et ensuite que ce que je
gagnais comme argent dans mes contrats,
je payais plein de charges dessus. Donc
lui c'est idiot. Je vais réduire mon
train de vie. Donc la porche l'Armanie,
je fil des copains véridique. Et ensuite
je me suis mise en communauté. Donc Mos
habitait avec moi mais je le payais pas.
On bossait ensemble et tous ses copains
venaient à la maison. On partageait ce
qu'on pouvait. Quand j'avais une demande
sur un truc de code, il me le faisait,
je le payais pas pour ça. Et puis
ensuite quand il avait besoin de gagner
de l'argent, il allait bosser à Linera,
faire un contrat. Puis il faisait ça
tout le temps. Puis moi, quand je
pouvais faire rentrer de l'argent, je le
faisais. Une grosse boîte qui veut
travailler avec mon ONG, bah je vais la
hacker, je vais ramener de l'argent. Ça
rentre dans la caisse pour payer les
autres, payer les étudiants, les
masters, les machines et tout ça. Et
donc moi, j'avais pas besoin de salarié
avec un niveau de vie très très réduit.
Ça me suffisait.
Question d'internet. Qu'est-ce que vous
pensez des alternatives à l'école ?
[soupir]
école type école démocratique ça parle
absolument d'ailleurs l'une des crapodes
s'appelle Marie Gervet elle a monté
l'école dynamique à l'époque avec Ramine
et elle l'a quitté pour essayer de faire
autre chose parce qu'elle trouvait que
c'était il y avait un certain nombre de
limitation je pas dans le détail mais
elle voulait aller plus loin encore.
Donc elle a monté l'école qui s'appelle
bah l'école tout court sur le plateau de
sa clé. C'est un truc de 0 à 18 ans.
Dedans, il y a un tierslieu le proto 204
qui est le tierslieu de Polytechnique.
Ensuite, il y a une crèche pour les
petits les petits gamins. Ensuite, il y
a tout le reste jusqu'à 18 ans. Et donc,
c'est appuyé par Tadi avec le cri mais
également avec Vilani. Et le but, c'est
que les gamins puissent aller apprendre
dans les labos de recherche qui sont à
côté parce que plateau de sa clé voilà
donc tu as Talè, Danon et tout ça et que
les gamins apprennent en allant voir les
autres font la recherche qui font de la
recherche également qu'ils apprennent
dans le proto. Donc c'est vraiment
l'idée de l'école apprenante. Donc on
est assez avancé sur le projet sachant
que Sylvie Retaillot qui est la doyenne
de l'Adie Versailles est très pour
aussi. Bon maintenant il faut trouver
des sous pour lancer le truc. Donc
j'aide un petit peu Marie là-dessus mais
c'est un beau projet parce qu'il va
beaucoup plus loin que les autres écoles
qui sont en général quand on est à une
petite classe deux trois classes
primairire ou collège mais qui ont pas
l'entièreté du truc.
On arrive à la fin de notre interview
qui d'ailleurs on demande à la
communauté de la sous-titrer en anglais
le plus rapidement possible.
Notre dernière question, ce qui n'est
pas une question, c'est laisser un
conseil pour les jeunes générations.
Une bouteille à la mer, quelque chose
qui peut perdurer après toi. Qu'est-ce
que tu pourrais laisser
[grognement]
par
revant ? Avant que tu répondes, je te
j'ai une autre question qui vient de
nous tomber.
Comment on crée le déclic pour faire le
pas de côté ? Est-ce qu'il faut un
événement extérieur exotique pour
catalyser tout ça ? Est-ce qu'il faut
s'imposer des des chocs ?
Non, je pense que simplement si
vous avez la chance de tomber par hasard
sur un bout du crapau fou les 2 minutes
à la télé ou autre ou cette émission et
que ça vous parle de simplement regarder
ce qu'il y a dedans, devenir une
conférence, dialoguer avec nous, ça
suffit. C'est le premier pas de côté
celui-là. Ensuite, le simple fait de
venir une fois, je l'ai vu dans toutes
les conférences qu'on a faites au début
il y a 30 personnes et à la fin les 30
sont connectés. C'est assez hallucinant
comme ça a pris de l'ampleur depuis et à
chaque fois les gens partent en me
disant "Mais j'ai passé une soir extra.
J'ai vraiment découvert quelque chose ce
soir." D'autres personnes qui pensaient
comme moi, j'ai découvert que c'était
possible. Donc après quand il y a une
masse critique, on crée donc une
courorte à Marseille, à Lille, à Ex, à
Brest et cetera. Dans les entreprises
dont j'ai parlé.
Est-ce que tu [grognement] es surveillé
par les services de renseignement ? Je
pense pas non parce qu'en plus comme ce
que je fais est vraiment toujours en
appui d'autres personnes qui vont
commencer à faire on va peut-être voir
le truc à Lille, on va voir le truc ici
ou là et peut-être qu'ils se diront que
c'est mais en réalité même pas parce que
c'est gens qui prennent mes idées qui
vivent avec après donc c'est plus moi.
Donc c'est pour ça que c'est pas ça me
pose pas de problème de ce côté-là. Et
donc
je crois vraiment que c'est le premier
pas. C'est si ça vous interpelle c'est
possible. Donc venez nous voir et on va
vous mettre le pied à l'étrier de
quelque chose. Mais cette chose elle
vient de vous. C'est pas moi qui vais
vous le dire. Vous allez vous mettre un
peu à poil, parler des choses qui vous
touchent et puis je vais vous trouver
quelqu'un qui est borderline ou qui est
codeur ou qui fait ceci ou qui fait cela
et on va se rendre compte qu'on est sur
un territoire voisin ou que peut-être le
gars qui est à Lille peut aider le mec
qui est à Numea et celui qui est à
Shenzen a plein de solutions pour tout
le monde et ça va connecter une séripité
plus qu'exponentielle. C'est ça la
promesse.
Il y a des mariages chez les crapaufous.
Il y a des mariages virtuels parce que
tu vois avec Mose, on a toujours été
vraiment complice dans l'âme mais on
s'est pas marié physiquement mais on
peut dire qu'on a fait plein de bébés et
c'est une seule manière ce que je vois
avec les crapaux maintenant quand je te
parle de Christian Ali Marie Gervet sur
le plateau de sa cl et je peux te donner
50 noms là ils sont tous en mouvement
ils font des trucs extra et ça croise
tout le temps. C'est vraiment assez
assez étonnant. Le conseil pour les
jeunes générations,
bah je crois que je dirais d'abord ne
pas désespérer et surtout c'est même pas
ça d'ailleurs, c'est laisser votre
folie. Euh ayez confiance dans votre
folie. Donc si on vous dit "Tu es trop
fou", bah au contraire, je dirais
continue au contraire à essayer de dans
cette piste là. Et ensuite bah dans
cette folie tout ce qui est un peu
marrant, qui est un peu créatif et quand
même je dirais euh j'espère qu'ils
auront perçu ces messages aussi bien du
Dailama que du crapauf qu'il faut quand
même revenir à la question fondamentale
qui est vers quoi va cette espèce donc
c'est ces trois tsunamis quel est le
monde qu'on veut demain ? Est-ce qu'on
veut Black Mirror ou est-ce qu'on veut
Bright Mirror ? Et j'espère qu'ils ont
au moins perçu que la réponse est dans
leurs mains. Voilà
Tan, merci. Merci à toi. Merci à vous
les gars. Couper.